I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Good morning, Office ladies! I see what you're doing there.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。早上好，办公室女郎们！我看到你在干什么了。
You see what I'm doing. You're tipping your hat a little to this episode. It's Dwight's speech, season two, episode 17, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by... Action! Charles McDougall. Wow, I've blown out my voice already. Someone driving right now is like, that's not the only thing you blew out.
你知道我在干什么。你对这一集稍稍致敬了一下。这是德怀特的演讲，第二季第十七集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，导演是……行动！查尔斯·麦克杜格尔。哇，我的嗓子已经喊哑了。现在正在开车的人可能会想，哑的还不止你的嗓子呢。
I know. Three sentences in. Thanks. I was driving when you were like, good morning, Office ladies. All right. I'll tone it down. I know. I'm going to NPR it now.
我知道。才说了三句话。谢谢。我开车的时候，你突然来了句“早上好，办公室女郎们”。好吧。我会收敛一点的。我知道。我现在要用NPR（美国国家公共电台）的语调了。
Oh. NPR voice. I'm going to do my summary, but I'm going to do it real gentle. Like that? Yeah. NPR voice? Yeah. Hi.
哦。NPR的语调。我要做剧情梗概了，但我会用非常温柔的语气说。就像这样？是的。NPR的语调？是的。嗨。
Welcome to Office, ladies. I'm Angela Kinsey. I'm Jenna Fisher. We're best friends and we're breaking down an episode of Dwight's speech from The Office. Here's the summary. All right. I'll stop it now. Dwight is named Salesperson of the Year.
欢迎来到办公室女郎。我是安吉拉·金西。我是珍娜·费舍。我们是好朋友，我们正在剖析《办公室》里德怀特的演讲这一集。以下是剧情梗概。好吧。我这就停下。德怀特被评为年度最佳销售员。
It's a big honor. Yeah. And as a result, he has to give a speech in front of a thousand people. And he's really nervous. So he goes to Michael for advice, then he goes to Jim for advice, eventually he goes to the conference, but meanwhile Pam is doing wedding prep at work in front of Jim. Oh, Jim. So he decides it's time for a vacation.
这是一个很大的荣誉。是的。因此，他必须在一千人面前发表演讲。他真的很紧张。于是他去找迈克尔寻求建议，然后去找吉姆寻求建议，最后他去了会议现场，但与此同时，帕姆在吉姆面前的工作时间筹备婚礼。噢，吉姆。于是他决定是时候去度假了。
A vacay. Also, there is a thermostat war going on. Yes. Yes. Thermostat war. Now, I had told some of our writers about the thermostat war that we had. Because you had one. We had one at 1-800-DENIS that resulted in a lock box over the thermostat with a key.
去度假。此外，还有一场恒温器大战正在上演。是的。是的。恒温器大战。现在，我曾向我们的编剧们提起过我们经历的那场恒温器大战。因为你们经历过。我们在1-800-DENIS公司也经历过一场，结果是在恒温器外面加装了一个带锁的保护盒并上了锁。
It got serious. It got serious. Um, so. What were you? Were you a colder or a hotter? I was a Jenna. I mean, for our listeners who might not know that you're wearing a puffy coat as we record this podcast.
事情变得严肃了。事情变得严肃了。嗯，所以。你是哪一派？你是喜欢冷还是喜欢热？我是一个珍娜。我是说，对于那些可能不知道我们录制这个播客时你穿着一件羽绒服的听众来说。
Right now, I have a T- Guys, literally she's wearing a puffy coat. That's not a joke. I have a sweatshirt on, a sweatshirt with a hoodie, and then I have an enormous puffer over that. Yeah. I also own a sweatshirt that says always cold. Yeah.
现在，我穿着一件T——伙计们，说真的，她穿着一件羽绒服。这不是开玩笑。我穿着一件运动衫，一件带帽的运动衫，然后我在外面套了一件巨大的羽绒服。是的。我还拥有一件上面写着“总是很冷”的运动衫。是的。
It was a gift to me. I didn't even buy it for myself. People know you. People know me. No. I was always cold. And for whatever reason where I sat on the phones is where all the air went, like our wing and the guys in the IT department, no air went to them.
这是别人送我的礼物。甚至都不是我自己买的。人们了解你。人们了解我。不。我总是觉得冷。不管什么原因，我坐的那个地方正对着所有的风，就像我们的侧楼和IT部门的小伙子们那样，他们那边一点风也没有。
So they were like the sweatiest. They were always annoyed. They would come over really sweaty and like shove the thermostat down. And then they'd walk away. We'd get cold and we'd crank it back up. Wow. They hated our corner. The IT guys hated our corner.
所以他们就像是最容易出汗的人。他们总是很恼火。他们会满头大汗地走过来，狠狠地把恒温器调低。然后他们就走开了。我们觉得冷，然后又把它调高。哇。他们讨厌我们的角落。IT部门的小伙子们讨厌我们的角落。
Fastback number one. We had a lot of questions about the convention center, the convention itself, a lot of curiosity. For example, fan question from Mary Ann Lodens and Grace Dee and Mel Asako. There was the speech filmed. And then Sue Potts asked, did we hire a bunch of extras or did we just use existing hotel people? Well, I reached out to our line producer, Kent Sabornak. So a line producer is the person who gets the script and figures out all of the practical
花絮一。我们收到了很多关于会议中心、会议本身的问题，大家充满了好奇。例如，来自玛丽安·洛登斯、格蕾丝·迪和梅·阿萨科的粉丝提问。演讲是在哪里拍摄的。然后苏·波茨问，我们是雇了一群群众演员，还是只用了酒店原有的员工？嗯，我联系了我们的制片主任，肯·萨伯纳克。制片主任就是那个拿到剧本并想出所有实际操作细节的人。
stuff that you need to do to make an episode happen. So whereas Greg Daniels is in charge of all the creative aspects of an episode, Kent Sabornak would be in charge of the practicals. And the logistics. Yes. How do I get people there? Where are we filming? What does it cost?
为了拍好一集电视剧，你需要做这些实际工作。因此，如果说格雷格·丹尼尔斯负责一集电视剧的所有创意方面，那么肯·萨伯纳克将负责实际操作。还有后勤。是的。我怎么把人弄到那儿去？我们在哪里拍摄？成本是多少？
Yes. How do we make this work with our budget? All of that kind of stuff. Yes. For example, he would be a person who would give Phil Shea a budget for 13 fitness orbs. He'd be like, here's your fitness orb budget. So he's in charge of all those numbers and things. He said that we filmed for only one day at the Universal Studios Sheridan Hotel.
是的。我们如何在预算内完成这一切？所有这类事情。是的。例如，他会给菲尔·谢伊一个购买13个健身球的预算。他会说，这是你的健身球预算。所以他负责所有这些数字和事情。他说我们在环球影城喜来登酒店只拍了一天。
Now I had written in my blog a while ago that we had 500 extras. But Kent said, we did not have 500 extras. We had 400 extras and 100 dummies. Bodies? Yes. Fake bodies. Torsos with no arms and legs, dressed up in suits. And five dummy wranglers, people who carried them around the room and put them in different
我在不久前写的博客里写过我们有500名群众演员。但肯说，我们没有500名群众演员。我们有400名群众演员和100个假人。尸体？是的。假尸体。没有胳膊和腿的躯干，穿着西装。还有五个假人管理员，负责把它们在房间里搬来搬去，并根据镜头需要把它们放在不同的地方。
places depending on the shots. I mean, that is crazy town. That is crazy town. I did have in my notes that we had about 400 extras and it's the most extras we had ever had. Yes. This is true. So Kent said that the dummies were mostly in the back and on the sides.
我的天呐，这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。我的笔记里确实写着我们大约有400名群众演员，这是我们有史以来用过的最多群众演员的一次。是的。这是真的。所以肯说假人主要在后面和两侧。
Yes. He said, if you pause and look, you can find them. But I went frame by frame and I could not find any. You know, the room was really. I mean, I really looked. So there were, there were only three cast members that went to the convention and it was, you know, rain, obviously Dwight speech and then Michael and myself. The room was actually really big.
是的。他说，如果你暂停画面仔细看，你能找到它们。但我一帧一帧地找，却什么也没找到。你知道的，那个房间真的。我是说，我真的很认真地找了。所以，去参加会议的演员只有三个，分别是雷恩，显然是德怀特的演讲，然后是迈克尔和我自己。房间其实真的很大。
And if my memory serves, they, they had the dummies sort of way towards the back. So it just looked like the room was filled all the way to the back. I wouldn't think that you could catch it. I think that'd be pretty hard. He mentioned that Charles McDougal was really worried that you were going to see these dummies. Yeah. And so the Wranglers really moved them around a lot. The dummy Wranglers.
如果我的记忆没出错的话，他们把假人差不多摆在很靠后的地方。所以看起来整个房间从前往后都坐满了。我想你不会那么容易察觉到的。我觉得这挺难的。他提到查尔斯·麦克杜格尔真的很担心大家会看到这些假人。是的。所以管理员们真的把它们挪动了很多次。假人管理员。
The dummy Wranglers. What's interesting to me. Is that, is that our book? The dummy. The dummy Wranglers. No, that's Kent Sabornat's book about dealing with us. Yeah. There were a lot of extras.
假人管理员。让我觉得有趣的是。是，那是我们的书吗？假人。假人管理员。不，那是肯·萨伯纳特关于如何应付我们的书。是的。有很多群众演员。
There were, it was the most I had ever seen. We had never really had to provide lunch for that many people. Like I remember when it came time for lunch, like the catering was way, it was like Sergio plus all these other extra guys that was our catering company. So it was kind of interesting to see how we manage that many people. And I, I was glad we only had to do it for one day. He said that we did 47 camera setups in a 12 hour shoot day. Now let me break that down for you guys.
确实有，这是我见过最多的一次。我们从没真正为这么多人提供过午餐。就像我记得到了吃午饭的时候，餐饮服务规模庞大，除了塞尔吉奥还有其他好几个外包的家伙，那成了我们的餐饮公司。所以看到我们如何管理这么多人还是挺有趣的。而且，我很高兴我们只需要应付一天。他说我们在一个为期12小时的拍摄日里完成了47个机位设置。现在让我来为你们分解一下。
When you do scenes, you might do like one scene at reception, but it's three or four different camera setups. So you'll do what usually like four to seven takes per camera setup, because, you know, and then you move the cameras and you do it again. But that blew my mind. He said that we started at 7am, wrapped around 730 and managed to shoot seven and four eighths pages, which I guess is a fancy way to say seven and a half. Okay.
当你拍摄场景时，你可能只在前台拍一个场景，但它涉及三到四个不同的机位设置。所以你通常每个机位设置会拍四到七条，因为，你知道的，然后你移动摄像机再拍一次。但那让我大开眼界。他说我们早上7点开始，7点半左右收工，设法拍了七页又八分之四页，我想这是一种花哨的说法，意思是七页半。好吧。
Fast fact number two, Rainn Wilson was very sick for this episode. Very, very sick. So we just explained to you everything that went into planning this work day. We had to, yeah, oh, yeah, go. We had to, they had it all scheduled and then they had to cancel it and reschedule it for a different day by a week. But just cancel it like a few days ahead. Basically Rainn was sick the beginning of the episode and then the day this was scheduled,
花絮二，雷恩·威尔逊在拍这一集时病得很重。非常、非常生病。所以我们刚刚向你们解释了筹备这个工作日所经历的一切。我们不得不，啊，对，去。我们不得不，他们把一切都安排好了，然后他们不得不取消并重新安排到一周后的另一天。但就在几天前突然取消。基本上雷恩在这一集刚开始时就生病了，然后在这个预定的拍摄日，
if I remember it was sort of like on a Wednesday or Thursday, we'd already done some office scenes in the bullpen and we were going later. I think it was a Wednesday. Yeah. I reached out to Kent about this as well and he said he always liked to put these location shoots on a Tuesday or a Wednesday. Yes. And go ahead.
如果我没记错的话，大概是在周三或周四，我们已经在办公大楼的大办公室里拍了一些办公室的场景，而且我们要拍到很晚。我想那是周三。是的。我也就此事联系了肯，他说他总是喜欢把这些外景拍摄安排在周二或周三。是的，请继续。
That's what I remember too. It was like a Wednesday, but we'd already been filming in the bullpen Monday, Tuesday, like the main office building. And I remember we only had the hotel for one day. It was a big deal because they had to reserve this room and everything. Yes. And then we had all the extras hired and everything. I woke up Wednesday morning and I got a call from our second AD and they said, Angela, the
这也是我的记忆。就像是一个周三，但我们周一、周二就已经在大办公室里拍戏了，也就是主办公楼。而且我记得我们只有一天时间使用这家酒店。这可是一件大事，因为他们必须预订这个房间等等。是的。然后我们还雇了所有的群众演员等等。我在周三早上醒来，接到了我们第二副导演的电话，他们说，安吉拉，
hotel's been canceled, Rainn is too sick. He's too sick. Like his doctor said, you cannot go. And I was like, oh my gosh. And so they were sort of scrambling now to figure out what Wednesday was going to look like. Well, I got a call at home, Jenna, the hotel has been canceled. You need to come in to work.
酒店取消了，雷恩病得太厉害了。他病得太重了。他的医生说，你不能去。我说，哦，天哪。所以他们现在正手忙脚乱地琢磨周三该怎么安排。嗯，我在家里接到了电话，珍娜，酒店取消了。你需要来上班。
We're going to be shooting back in the office now. Yeah. So I got the day off. And I was suddenly had to work. Yes. Well, I actually called Rainn about it and he said that it is the only time in 10 years of working on the office that he was not able to come to work for a day. But he had a fever over 102.
我们现在要回到办公室里拍摄了。是的。所以我放假了。而我突然不得不去工作了。是的。嗯，我其实为此给雷恩打了电话，他说这是他在《办公室》工作10年来唯一一次因为生病而有一天无法上班。但他的烧超过了102华氏度（约39摄氏度）。
He said, a doctor came and said, you cannot go to work. Rainn has a fantastic work ethic and I don't doubt that for him to miss, he was very ill. Well, we had a fan question from Chris Bodnar who kind of clocked it. He said, was Rainn Wilson sick during this episode because his voice sounds like he might have a cold. And Rainn said, actually, the voice thing is because he was screaming during the speech and he kind of blew out his voice. But you can actually hear in the conference room before we ever move to the hotel.
他说，医生来过并说，你不能去上班。雷恩有着极佳的职业道德，我毫不怀疑对缺勤这件事来说他是真的很生病。嗯，我们收到了克里斯·博德纳的粉丝提问，他注意到了这一点。他说，雷恩·威尔逊这一集生病了吗听起来他的声音好像有点感冒。雷恩说，其实，声音变了是因为他在演讲时大喊大叫，把嗓子喊哑了。但你实际上可以在我们搬去酒店之前的会议室里听到。
You can tell he's coming down with it. I could really tell. I heard his voice in the conference room. That's before we went to the hotel and he sounded legit sick. So I agree with you, Chris. I wonder if he got a phone call from Greg Daniels telling him it was his finest performance because he's really good in this episode. But yeah, I mean, the other thing too you should know is that Rainn really didn't want
你能听出他快要病倒了。我真的听出来了。我在会议室里听到了他的声音。那是我们去酒店之前，他听起来确实病得不轻。所以我同意你的看法，克里斯。我想知道他是否接到过格雷格·丹尼尔斯的电话，告诉他这是他最精彩的表演，因为他在这一集里真的演得很好。不过，是的，我是说，你们应该知道的另一件事是，雷恩其实不想
to miss work because he knew how much went into that day, the extras, the hotel, the location shoot. So I think the dummy wranglers, the dummy wranglers, I think he was really trying to power it out and then his body just couldn't. Yeah. All right. Fast fact number three, this was a little bit of trivia that I found on Dunderpedia. Dunderpedia, guys, is the Wikipedia of the office.
错过工作，因为他知道那天投入了多少心血，群众演员、酒店、外景拍摄。所以我想假人管理员，假人管理员，我想他当时真的是在咬牙坚持，然后他的身体实在撑不住了。是的。好吧，花絮三，这是我在Dunderpedia上找到的一点冷知识。伙计们，Dunderpedia就是《办公室》的维基百科。
It's great. It's just all office facts. It's great. And I found this charming. So this episode aired in the United States on March 2nd in 2006. However, in Canada, it aired the day before. Oh. It aired a day early and this was due to a scheduling conflict with the season finale
它太棒了。里面全是关于《办公室》的花絮。太棒了。我觉得这很有趣。所以这一集在美国播出是在2006年3月2日。然而，在加拿大，它提前一天播出了。哦。它提前一天播出了，这是因为与《名人滑冰秀》的大结局撞期了。
of Skating with Celebrities. Oh. So in the United States, we aired on NBC and Skating with Celebrities aired on Fox. But in Canada, they both aired on the same network, this global television network. And the finale of Skating with Celebrities was at the same time as this episode. So they had to air us one day early. So everyone in Canada got to see this one day early. Well, how about that?
哦。所以在美国，我们在全国广播公司（NBC）播出，《名人滑冰秀》在福克斯（Fox）播出。但在加拿大，它们在同一个电视台播出，也就是这个环球电视网。而《名人滑冰秀》的大结局和这一集的播出时间撞车了。所以他们不得不让我们提前一天播出。因此加拿大的每个人都提前一天看到了这一集。嗯，这怎么样？
Yeah. Who was on Skating with Celebrities? It only ran for one season. Did people get injured? I don't remember a bunch of injuries, but I weirdly remember the show. I don't. It only went for one season. So it wasn't a hit, I guess, this week.
是的。谁参加了《名人滑冰秀》？它只播了一季。有人受伤吗？我不记得有什么重伤，但我诡异地记得这个节目。我不记得了。它只播了一季。所以我想它本周并不轰动。
I'm kind of like. It wasn't. It didn't take off. Okay. So here, I'll give you the cast of Skating with Celebrities. I'm really curious. They matched a celebrity with a pro skating partner. So Christy Swanson, Jillian Barbary, Bruce Jenner, Dave Coulier, Debbie Gibson, and
我有点像。它并没有火。好吧。那么，我来给你们念一下《名人滑冰秀》的演员阵容。我真的很好奇。他们把一个名人和一个职业滑冰搭档凑成一对。有克里斯蒂·斯旺森、吉莉安·巴伯里、布鲁斯·詹纳、戴夫·库利尔、黛比·吉布森和
Todd Bridges. Christy Swanson won. Hey. She defeated Jillian Barbary and her partner to win the show's first and only championship. Wow. Yeah. Oh, here's something interesting. The very next day, it was announced that it was canceled.
托德·布里奇斯。克里斯蒂·斯旺森赢了。嘿。她击败了吉莉安·巴伯里和她的搭档，赢得了该节目第一届也是唯一一届冠军。哇。是的。哦，这里有个有趣的事。就在第二天，官方宣布它被取消了。
Oh, no. Yeah. So it's like, I won. Canceled. Canceled. I want bowling with celebrities. I'd do it. I would do it.
哦，不。是的。所以就像是，我赢了。被砍了。被砍了。我想和名人一起打保龄球。我会去的。我会去的。
You know, I got four strikes in a row the other day, Angela. I got like, what is that? That's more than a turkey. I don't. I just like the idea of like some kind of reality championship where I can have beer and like a slice of pizza while doing my activity. Bowling with celebrities. Bowling with celebrities.
你知道的，安吉拉，我前几天连续得了四个全中。我拿到了像，那是什么？那比火鸡（连续三个全中）还厉害。我不。我只是喜欢那种可以一边进行我的活动，一边喝啤酒吃披萨的真人秀冠军的想法。和名人一起打保龄球。和名人一起打保龄球。
What's that thing where you throw beanbags into a hole in your backyard? Cornhole. Cornhole. I love cornhole. Cornhole with celebrities. I do that all the time. I mean, I'm not, I'm sort of, you know, not major celebrity, but. Is cornhole also a phrase for something dirty?
后院里那种把沙包扔进洞里的游戏叫什么？地掷球（玉米洞）。玉米洞。我喜欢玉米洞。和名人一起玩玉米洞。我经常玩那个。我是说，我不是，我算是一个，你知道的，不是什么大名鼎鼎的名人，但是。玉米洞是不是也是什么下流说法的代名词？
Probably. Is it, it has to do with your butt, maybe, Sam? Why are we looking at you? Why are we looking at you? You don't have to look to me for every. Is that a reference for your butt hole? Also, here's the thing. Yes, it is.
很可能是。是不是，它跟你的屁股有关，对吧，萨姆？为什么我们要看着你？为什么我们要看着你？你不用什么事都指望我。那是对你屁股眼的代指吗？还有，事情是这样的。是的，它就是。
So maybe no cornhole with celebrities. It's still really fun. I mean, here's the thing. Here's my bowling strategy where I can't wait to hear it. Don't. Cut this. Every time I walk up and I just try to line up with that little center triangle. The arrow?
所以也许不要和名人一起玩玉米洞。它还是很好玩的。我是说，事情是这样的。这是我的保龄球策略，我迫不及待想听听了。别。剪掉这个。每次我走上去，我都试着对准那个小小的中心三角形。箭头？
Uh-huh. Yeah. And then I try to look at that and then I roll it down. The ball goes super slow. Okay. Cause I usually bowl with like a 10 pound ball. I'm like going fighting the kids for their balls. It's fascinating.
嗯哼。是的。然后我试着看着那个，然后我把它滚出去。球滚得超级慢。好吧。因为我通常用10磅的球。我像是在跟孩子们抢他们的球。这太迷人了。
It's fascinating. And the ball goes super slow. Don't stop. Super slow. And then I get like a strike, but it's like, it takes like five minutes. It's like dunk, dunk, dunk, dunk. And then I think cause the ball's going so slow, I usually there's like one or two left. I come really close to getting a strike.
这太迷人了。然后球滚得超级慢。别停。超级慢。然后我得到了一个全中，但感觉就像是，花了五分钟。就像是咚、咚、咚、咚。然后我想因为球滚得太慢了，通常会剩下一两个。我离拿到全中非常近。
So that, that's how I bowl. Don't stop talking about it, Angela. Keep telling me more details. I don't, I either do that or I just get a gutter ball. I would have pegged. So it's interesting to me. I will say now, I'm very interested. It's very interesting to me that you take the time to line it up and you do the thing.
所以，这就是我打保龄球的方式。别停下别说这个了，安吉拉。继续告诉我更多细节。我不会，我要么那样做，要么就直接扔成洗沟球。我本以为。所以这对我很有趣。我必须说，现在，我很感兴趣。你花时间去瞄准并做那个动作，这让我觉得很有趣。
You know, you go for the arrow because I might have pegged you as a person. Willy nilly. Not Willy nilly, but where you're like, I'm going to just chunk it. I'm going to chunk it real hard. Did you say chunk it? I did it for you. So you'd understand what I meant. Oh, shut up.
你知道的，你去瞄准那个箭头，因为我本以为你是一个那种人。随心所欲。不是随心所欲，而是那种你会说，我要把它狠狠地扔出去。你刚才说狠狠地扔出去（chunk it）吗？我是为你说的。这样你就能明白我的意思了。哦，闭嘴。
You shut it. It's time for a break. Oh, if anyone is still wanting to listen, we're going to get into the episode. There's some really good stuff. I have a lot of fun things to say. I do too. And it's not even going to be about bowling. Might be.
你才闭嘴。是时候休息一下了。哦，如果还有人想听的话，我们要进入这一集正片了。里面有一些非常棒的内容。我有很多有趣的事情要说。我也有。而且甚至跟打保龄球无关。也许有关。
Might be. All right. We'll see you after the break. Let's get started with this episode. Let's do it. We have a cold open. Michael and Dwight are throwing a football while they discuss some dilemma at corporate. It's not important.
也许有关。好吧。我们休息后见。让我们从这一集开始吧。开始吧。我们有一个冷场开场。迈克尔和德怀特一边扔橄榄球，一边讨论公司里的某种困境。这不重要。
I don't think it doesn't even mean anything. I will never forget this cold open. Oh boy. Tell. Okay. So Jim steals the ball. He tosses it to Phyllis. Phyllis tosses it to Creed.
我觉得这甚至没有任何意义。我永远不会忘记这个冷场开场。噢，天哪。讲讲。好吧。所以吉姆抢了球。他把它抛给菲利斯。菲利斯把它抛给克里德。
Dwight runs over and only the way that rain Wilson would do rain is he goes full out guys. Yeah. If the script says tackle shove, you're going to go flying. Yeah. Cause rain is Dwight is like all in. So like he tackles Ryan to the ground. Yep. He shoves the heck out of Creed and then he runs towards Leslie David Baker.
德怀特跑了过来，用只有雷恩·威尔逊才会用的雷恩式风格，他全力以赴，伙计们。是的。如果剧本写着冲撞扑倒，你就会飞出去。是的。因为雷恩饰演的德怀特是全情投入的。所以他把瑞恩扑倒在地。没错。他狠狠地撞了克里德，然后向莱斯利·大卫·贝克跑去。
Yeah. Who is standing by accounting. Okay. What you cannot see. Oh no. Is there is a petite blonde person standing behind him. Oh. Mm-hmm.
是的。他就站在会计部旁。好吧。你所看不到的是。哦，不。有一个娇小的金发碧眼的人站在他身后。哦。嗯-hmm。
Rain runs at Leslie and like Heisman's him basically. Yeah. He really gives him the stiff arm shove Leslie was not expecting it. Oh dear. It wasn't really in the script that he was going to shove Leslie. We had a stunt coordinator that day. We planned this out like super duper. Let me tell you something.
雷恩冲向莱斯利，基本上对他用了“赫斯曼冲刺（美式橄榄球中持球冲锋时用单臂推挡防守队员的动作）”。是的。他真的给了他一记僵直手臂的推击，莱斯利根本没料到。哦，天哪。剧本里并没有写他要推莱斯利。那天我们有一个特技协调员。我们把这个计划得超级无敌周密。让我告诉你一件事。
Leslie was not ready for that show. Okay. I think maybe, maybe with the stunt guy, he got a brisk little like tap or something. Uh-huh. Yeah, but rain came at him full throttle and like shoved him Leslie went flying. He lost. You can see it in the episode. He lost his balance completely.
莱斯利根本没准备好迎接那一推。好吧。我想也许，也许在特技演员的指导下，他会挨上一个轻快的、像拍一下之类的小动作。嗯哼。是的，但雷恩是全速向他冲过来，狠狠地把他推飞了出去。莱斯利完全失去了平衡。
He went almost butt overhead. Okay. Do you know what I'm saying? Yeah. But there was someone directly behind him. Tiny blonde. A tiny blonde person. So when Leslie lost his balance, he started steam rolling back and I was under that.
他差点屁股朝天翻过去。好吧。你知道我在说什么吗？是的。但有一个人直接站在他身后。娇小的金发。一个娇小的金发人。所以当莱斯利失去平衡时，他开始向后翻滚，而我就在那个位置下面。
Wow. I was under that. Well, it's crazy because I remember that we practiced that forever and I kind of remember it because all I do is sit at the reception desk and I had thought to myself, did I need to be here for the two hours? That's what I thought. They said, you know, definitely they didn't want me seated at my desk. They wanted me to come out a little bit to the edge of accounting.
哇。我就在那下面。嗯，这太疯狂了，因为我记得我们排练了很久很久，我有点记得是因为我唯一要做的事就是坐在前台接待处，我当时心里想，我有必要在那里待两个小时吗？我当时就是这么想的。他们说，你知道的，他们绝对不希望我坐在座位上。他们希望我稍微走到会计部的边缘。
Sometimes they would have us do that. If there's a scene in the main office bullpen and they want to get reaction shots of everyone, they would kind of have Kevin and my character come out. So they could see you better. So they could see us better. Of course. And so they had us come out, but Leslie did not think he was going to fall. He did not fall in any of the rehearsals.
有时他们会让我们这么做。如果大办公室里有一场戏，他们想捕捉每个人的反应镜头，他们就会让凯文和我这个角色走出来。这样他们能更好地看到你。这样他们能更好地看到我们。当然。所以他们让我们出来了，但莱斯利根本没想到自己会摔倒。他在任何一次排练中都没有摔倒过。
He wasn't shoved that hard. Yeah. Well, he wasn't being shoved by Rainn Wilson yet. No, he wasn't. So Leslie went flying and collided into me and then rolled backwards on top of me. And after the take, everyone was like, oh my God, Creed, are you okay? Creed. And then they were like, oh, BJ, are you okay?
他没有被推得那么狠。是的。嗯，那时他还没被雷恩·威尔逊推呢。不，他没有。所以莱斯利飞了出去，撞到了我，然后向后倒在我身上。拍完这条之后，每个人都在喊，哦，天哪，克里德，你没事吧？克里德。然后他们喊，哦，BJ，你没事吧？
And then they're like, oh my God, Leslie, because Leslie really went down hard. They're like, Leslie, are you okay? Leslie up. And Oscar goes, oh my God, Angela. Oscar was like the only person that saw me. I was like, yeah. And then I don't know if you notice, but all of this happens at one minute. If you look at the time code.
然后他们喊，哦，天哪，莱斯利，因为莱斯利真的是重重地摔了下去。他们喊，莱斯利，你没事吧？莱斯利起来了。奥斯卡说，哦，天哪，安吉拉。奥斯卡好像是唯一看到我的人。我说，我没事。然后我不知道你们有没有注意到，这一切都发生在第一分钟。如果你看时间码的话。
Okay. Now go to one minute, five seconds. Leslie is no longer there. Oh, like he was take, did he only do the first take? I don't know, Jenna, how it went down. But I think he got knocked down and then got up and was like, nope. Well, I don't know if you notice at 20 seconds when Michael tosses the ball and he knocks over Jim's stuff on his desk. It all kinds of falls forward onto this pile of boxes that's in front of Dwight's desk.
好吧。现在跳到一分零五秒。莱斯利已经不在那里了。哦，就像他是被，他只拍了第一条吗？我不知道，珍娜，当时是怎么回事。但我猜他被撞倒了然后站起来说，不。嗯，我不知道你们在20秒时有没有注意到，当迈克尔扔球时，他撞翻了吉姆桌上的东西。它们全都向前倒在了德怀特桌子前的一堆箱子上。
If you look at 42 seconds, Michael tosses the ball to Oscar and all those boxes are missing. They were cleared and not returned. So look at us. Little continuity catch. Little catches there in the background. I did want to throw out to Rihanna Royer who had written in to ask if the football toss was planned. And so we answered that question, but I do thank you for writing in. Yes.
如果你看42秒，迈克尔把球扔给奥斯卡，所有那些箱子都不见了。它们被清理掉了，而且没有再放回来。所以看看我们。小小的连贯性抓包。背景里有一些小小的穿帮。我确实想向瑞安·罗伊尔致意，他写信来询问橄榄球互扔是不是计划好的。所以我们回答了那个问题，但我真的很感谢你写信来。是的。
No, that was all planned. Although Leslie's. That part wasn't planned. Leslie's. Angela's getting squashed was not planned. All right. So now we move on. Dwight is sitting at his desk and he is talking about, oh, a sale on Tevo.
不，那都是计划好的。虽然莱斯利的。那部分不是计划好的。莱斯利的。安吉拉被压扁不是计划好的。好吧。现在我们继续。德怀特坐在他的桌子旁，他在谈论，哦，Tevo有折扣。
He's going to buy something special for himself because he is salesperson of the year. Hold up. This is an old tech alert though. Tevo. Tevo. He talks about a CD burner. We also find out that Jim came in ninth place and all he's getting is Cajino's pizza. Yeah.
他要给自己买个特别的东西，因为他是年度最佳销售员。等等。这是一个老旧的技术警报。Tevo。Tevo。他谈到一个刻录机。我们还发现吉姆得了第九名，他得到的只有卡吉诺披萨。是的。
But you guys, do any of you have Tevos? Did you have a Tevo? I had a Tevo. Yeah. Okay. Young people. Tevo was like a VCR. That one of the very first digital video recordings where you could record your show.
但是伙计们，你们有谁用过Tevo吗？你们有Tevo吗？我有Tevo。是的。好吧，年轻人。Tevo就像是录像机。它是最早能够录制节目的数字视频录像机之一。
Yeah. It's the same as what you have now on your direct TV or your cable. But we didn't have that. We didn't have that. You had to hook it into your cable box. These were the days where like if you had a VHS player, you could record one of your shows. But like this changed it because it digitally recorded things and you could like plan out
是的。它和你们现在在Direct TV或有线电视上用的一样。但我们那时没有。我们那时没有。你必须把它插到有线电视盒里。那是如果你有一个VHS播放器，你可以录制其中一个节目的年代。但这改变了一切，因为它能以数字方式录制东西，你可以计划好
your records. You didn't have to like run home and hit the record button. I feel like this is like my mom trying to tell me about what life was like without a microwave. I'm like, I don't care. I just want to heat up some soup. Tevo was a game changer. It was.
你的录像。你不用像以前那样跑回家去按录制按钮。我觉得这就像是我妈妈试图向我描述没有微波炉的生活是什么样的。我会说，我不在乎。我只想热一碗汤。Tevo是一个时代的颠覆者。确实是的。
I was so excited to have Tevo. There was one moment in February of 2004 that Tevo had the most watch recorded and replayed moment in Tevo history. What was it? It was Janet Jackson's Super Bowl. Half time with Justin Timberlake. The little, the boob slip. Where the boob came out.
我当时能拥有Tevo简直太兴奋了。2004年2月有一个时刻，Tevo创造了Tevo历史上观看、录制和回放次数最多的时刻。是什么？那是珍妮·杰克逊的超级碗。与贾斯汀·汀布莱克的半场秀。那个，露胸事件。乳房露出来的那个。
Yes. That was the most watch recorded and replayed moment in Tevo history. The folks at Tevo said the audience reaction charts looked like an electrocardiogram. Oh, my God. Like, tic-tac-tac-tac-tac-tac-tac-tac-tac-tac-tac. I mean. That is crazy. That'll cross it.
是的。那是Tevo历史上观看、录制和回放次数最多的时刻。Tevo的工作人员说，观众的反应图表看起来就像是一张心电图。哦，天哪。就像是，嘀-哒-嘀-哒-嘀-哒-嘀-哒-嘀-哒。我是说。太疯狂了。这太夸张了。
So you know when Jim says he just wins a Cajinos pizza? Yes. This is the second time Jim has mentioned Cajinos. He also brought it up in a deleted scene from the client where he says his worst first date took place at Cugino's Pizza. This is a real Italian restaurant. It is in Dunmore right outside of Scranton. It's actually at 107 East Drinker Street in Dunmore. They do serve pizza, but I could not find a website for them or an online menu. But guys, it's a little family-owned business, Cugino's Pizza. Put it on your The Office tour, because when I was looking up stuff
所以你知道当吉姆说他只赢得了一份卡吉诺披萨时吗？是的。这是吉姆第二次提到卡吉诺。他在《客户》一集的删减片段中也提到过，他说他最糟糕的第一次约会发生在卡吉诺披萨店。这是一家真正的意大利餐厅。它位于斯克兰顿郊外的邓莫尔。它实际上位于邓莫尔东德林克街107号。他们确实卖披萨，但我找不到他们的网站或在线菜单。但是伙计们，这是一家小型家族企业，卡吉诺披萨。把它加入你的《办公室》巡礼路线中，因为当我为这一集查阅资料时，
for this episode, I found these websites that you can do sort of like a little travel vacation where you hit all the stops of the office. Yeah, so go get some pizza at Cugino's. Guys, I want to present to you at 2 minutes 31 seconds, a complete tongue twister. Okay. Ready? Yeah. I want you guys, Sam, wake up in there. I want you guys to try to say this 10 times fast. Okay, ready? Yeah. It is literally the highest possible honor that a Northeastern Pennsylvania-based mid-sized paper company regional salesman can attain. Oh, that's from Jim's talking head. Yes. But how did he memorize that? But how did he get it all in like one sentence? That is not easy. That is not easy. All right, applause, John. Well done, John Krasinski. Jim tongue twister. Okay, where are we at?
我发现了一些网站，你可以进行那种打卡《办公室》所有取景地的小型旅游度假。是的，去卡吉诺吃点披萨吧。伙计们，我想在2分31秒处向你们展示一个绝对的绕口令。好吧。准备好了吗？是的。我希望你们，萨姆，醒醒。我希望你们试着把这个快速说10遍。好吧，准备好了吗？是的。这绝对是宾夕法尼亚州东北部中型纸业公司区域销售人员所能获得的最高荣誉。哦，那是吉姆的单人访谈。是的。但他是怎么记住这一大串的？但他怎么能一口气把它全说在同一个句子里的？这可真不简单。这真不简单。好吧，鼓掌，约翰。干得好，约翰·卡拉辛斯基。吉姆的绕口令。好吧，我们讲到哪儿了？
Well, speaking of Jim, we are finally in the kitchen with Jim and Pam, and they are finally bantering again like old times. They're flirting. Oh, they're so cute. Nice little back and forth. There's been this drought. They've been a bit estranged, and it looks like things are going to thaw until Phyllis comes out of the bathroom and asks Pam about her wedding dress. So awkward. And Jim makes kind of a quick exit. At two minutes, 40 seconds, there's a shot of Jim's coffee mug, and it says, quote, together we build a better Scranton, restoring the pride. And Dunderpedia pointed out that this was the motto of a downtown Scranton revitalization project. And you will see Jim use this mug throughout the entire episode. Way to go.
嗯，说到吉姆，我们终于来到了厨房，吉姆和帕姆在那里，他们终于像过去那样开始互损了。他们在调情。哦，他们太可爱了。很好的小互动。之前一直有一段冷淡期。他们有点疏离，看起来冰山就要融化了，直到菲利斯从卫生间出来，向帕姆打听她的婚纱。太尴尬了。吉姆很快就溜走了。在两分四十秒处，有一个吉姆咖啡杯的特写，上面写着，引述一下，齐心协力共建更好的斯克兰顿，重振昔日荣光。Dunderpedia指出，这是斯克兰顿市中心一个振兴项目的座右铭。你会看到吉姆在整集中都用着这个杯子。干得好。
That's Phil Shea putting some local props in play. Phil Shea, but also good catches there. Yeah, local pizza place, local mug. So now we go to Pam's talking head, and she says, listen, I just, I have to do my wedding planning at the office, you know, but it can get weird sometimes. And she's worried about people getting offended like Angela. Look what I wrote on my card. What? Leave me out of it. Leave me out of it. This has nothing to do with me and your scandalous emotional affair you're having. Leave me out of it. All right. So now Dwight is feeding himself grapes at his desk. And Michael enters and says, that's what she said, because grapes seductive. And he asked Dwight if he's ready for his big speech. Well, I have real beef with Michael on
那是菲尔·谢伊在道具中加入了一些本土元素。菲尔·谢伊，还有那些不错的细节。是的，当地的披萨店，当地的杯子。现在我们来到帕姆的单人访谈，她说，听着，我只是，我必须在办公室筹备我的婚礼，你知道的，但这有时会变得很诡异。她担心人们会像安吉拉那样感到被冒犯。看看我在卡片上写了什么。什么？别把我扯进去。别把我扯进去。这跟我一点关系都没有，也跟你那见不得人的情感出轨无关。别把我扯进去。好吧。现在德怀特正坐在桌子旁吃葡萄。迈克尔走进来，说，这也是她说的，因为葡萄很诱惑。他问德怀特准备好做重要演讲了吗？嗯，我对迈克尔在这一集里的表现有很大的意见。
this episode. Talk to me about it. He does not want Dwight to succeed. He doesn't. He is flat out mean to him. He's psyching him out. Yeah. He's negative. He's putting him down the whole episode. So Angela, the Angela Martin in me is like, you are not being nice. No. Then Jim goes on to sabotage Dwight. Like why? Why is everyone coming down on Dwight? Well, is it because he's a little bit rubbing it in everyone's face? I think Jim had motivation because Dwight's rubbing it in his face. That's fine. They have that back and forth. But Dwight just adores Michael and hangs on his every word and isn't rubbing it in his face. Michael is just, I think jealous that someone else has the spotlight. He's like a little bratty kid. He also puts himself in this position
跟我说说。他不想让德怀特成功。他真不想。他对德怀特简直刻薄透顶。他在打击他的自信心。是的。他很消极。整集都在贬低他。所以安吉拉，我体内的安吉拉·马丁就觉得，你一点都不友好。不。然后吉姆接着去破坏德怀特的计划。为什么？为什么每个人都要针对德怀特？嗯，是不是因为他有点把这事挂在每个人脸上了？我觉得吉姆有动机，因为德怀特在往他脸上炫耀。这没关系。他们有那种你来我往的互动。但德怀特只是崇拜迈克尔，对他的话言听计从，并没有在迈克尔面前炫耀。迈克尔只是，我觉得他是在嫉妒别人抢了风头。他就像个有点幼稚的小屁孩。他还把自己摆在专家的位置上。
of expert. So he's got this talking head now where he explains that he won salesman of the year twice before consecutively, twice in a row. But one year he got a plaque. The other year he just got a certificate. Well, they stopped making plaques. Right. Can we talk about where this talking head takes place? In his cabinet. Inside his like man armoire. Yes. In his office. Yes. At four minutes one second, you get a really good shot of it. Did you look and see what else inside? You know I did. You know you did. Okay. Let's let's trade some stuff. Break it down. Is that Jan on the cover of the Dunder Mifflin newsletter? Yeah. Did you see that her name is still listed as Gould? No. So how long has that been there? He's saved it for a bit. It's pre Gould. Okay.
所以他现在有了一个单人访谈，在访谈中他解释说他以前连续两次获得过年度最佳销售员，两次连着拿。但有一年他得到了一块牌匾。另一年他只得到了一张奖状。嗯，他们不再制作牌匾了。对吧。我们能谈谈这个单人访谈是在哪儿拍的吗？在他的柜子里。就像在他的男士衣柜里。是的。在他的办公室里。是的。在四分零一秒处，你得到了一个非常清晰的特写镜头。你有没有看里面还有什么？你知道我看了。你知道你看了。好吧。让我们交换一下信息。细分一下。那是詹登上《邓内尔·米夫林通讯》的封面吗？是的。你看到她的姓氏仍然列为古尔德吗？没有。所以这上面挂了多久了？他留着它有一阵子了。这是古尔德之前的事。好吧。
He's got a mirror. He's got a mini fridge, but on the top shelf of his mini fridge is a fancy silver tea set. Yeah. It's not a mini fridge. That's a safe. That's a safe. He has a safe that he has gotten his plaque and certificate out of and then the top shelf of the safe. There is a tea set. This makes a lot more sense. I mean kind of. It's still strange. I was like, why is he refrigerating? Why is he chilling the whole tea set? Yeah. Like why is this? And then also why is he chosen to chill a plaque? But he hung two other plaques. They're not worthy of the mini fridge. Safe. Well, he also has Pepto-Bismol deodorant, toothbrush and toothpaste and a can of something. A can of something. And then what are those two squares? Like a couple of
他有一面镜子。他有一个迷你冰箱，但迷你冰箱的最上面一层是一个精致的银色茶具。是的。那不是迷你冰箱。那是一个保险箱。那是一个保险箱，他把他的牌匾和奖状从里面拿出来，然后保险箱的最顶层。放着一套茶具。这就说得通多了。我是说，某种程度上。这还是很奇怪。我当时想，他为什么要冷藏？他为什么要冷藏整套茶具？是的。这算怎么回事？然后为什么他选择冷藏一块牌匾？但他把另外两块牌匾挂起来了。它们不配进迷你冰箱。保险箱。嗯，他还有健胃消食片、除臭剂、牙刷和牙膏，以及一罐什么东西。一罐什么东西。然后那两个方块是什么？就像几个
items like wrapped in mesh with some twine. It looked like it. It looked like it. We don't know. We don't know. It was weird. He had a change of clothes, a dundee. Yep. Two mounted plaques. It looked like maybe a silver shot glass and a blue cup. Huh. There you go. Michael's credenza. Mini fridge. Which is a safe. I really need to start watching these episodes with my glasses on. Clearly. Clearly. Look at that mini fridge. It's a safe Angela. Guys, at four minutes, 23 seconds, Dwight has this great talking head where he talks about losing his sixth grade spelling beat for not being able to spell the word failure. That was an improvisation. Rain improvised that part of it where that the word was failure. That is fantastic, Rain. That's
用网眼包裹并用麻绳系着的物品。看起来是的。看起来是。我们不知道。我们不知道。这太诡异了。他有一身换洗衣服，一个邓迪奖杯。没错。两块挂起来的牌匾。看起来可能是一个银色小酒杯和一个蓝色杯子。哼。给你。迈克尔的餐边柜。迷你冰箱。其实是个保险箱。我真的需要戴着眼镜看这些剧集了。显然。显然。看看那个迷你冰箱。那是保险箱，安吉拉。伙计们，在四分二十三秒处，德怀特有一个非常棒的单人访谈，他在访谈中谈到自己在六年级拼写比赛中因为不会拼写“failure（失败）”这个词而落败。那是即兴发挥。雷恩即兴发挥了那部分内容，那个词是“failure”。太棒了，雷恩。这
good. I think you can really start hearing that he's sick and that talking head and later in the conference room scenes, I really heard it. Okay. So you know the scene in Michael's office where he's telling Dwight, I'm going to, I'm going to mentor you. I can teach you enough so you don't embarrass yourself during this speech. If you look in the background over Rain's shoulder, and you can see reception in the background, and it's me and Kate, and we're back there. And here is something that's very interesting. Whenever I did background work with Kate, we stayed in character the whole time. You can see us crouching over Pam's computer, and we did a whole runner about our frustration with the new computer system that won't allow us
很好。我想你真的能开始听出他生病了，在那个单人访谈和后来的会议室场景中，我真的听出来了。好吧。所以你知道迈克尔办公室里的那个场景，他在告诉德怀特，我要，我要指导你。我可以教你足够的知识，这样你在演讲时就不会出丑了。如果你看雷恩肩膀上方的背景，你能看到背景中的前台，我和凯特在那儿，我们在后面。这里有一件非常有趣的事。每当我和凯特做背景戏份时，我们自始至终都保持着角色状态。你可以看到我们俯身在帕姆的电脑前，我们围绕对新电脑系统的不满编了一整套台词，这个系统不允许我们在销售订单中输入字母和数字混合代码，这是一个巨大的问题。
to enter both alpha and numeric codes into the sales orders, and that it was a huge problem. And I wrote about it in my diary, and I said that we stayed in character the entire two hours that they shot in Michael's office. By the way, that's the smartest Meredith was written in the whole series. Was in our background improvisations. That's the most competent Meredith has ever sounded. They were the most fun to me. We always had the best time, Kate and I, because we would come up with these, it was always something we were annoyed with. It was always some new office procedure, and we would kind of complain about it and try to figure it out. Yeah. Oscar and I would do bits like that. We would totally stay in character, but what we were talking about would
我在日记里写下了这件事，我说在迈克尔办公室拍摄的那两个小时里，我们自始至终都保持着角色状态。顺便说一句，那是整部剧里对梅雷迪思最聪明的塑造。就在我们的背景即兴发挥中。那是梅雷迪思听起来最能干的一次。对我来说那些是最有趣的。我和凯特总是玩得最开心，因为我们会想出这些点子，总是某种让我们感到恼火的事情。总是一些新的办公室程序，我们会对此发牢骚并试图解决它。是的。奥斯卡和我也会做这样的桥段。我们会完全保持角色状态，但我们讨论的内容会
be absolutely ridiculous. He would very seriously pass me papers, important payroll papers, but he would have attached a post-it note that would say, will you please file these in your butt? And then he would draw like a little cartoon with it, and it always like cracked me up. Well, I just thought it was really sweet because I, you know, we go back to our diaries and we read what we wrote, and I had written all about how much fun I had on this episode, filming with Kate in the background of that scene. That's so cute. I love that. Yeah, I know. All right. So next we cut to Pam's desk, and she is on the phone with her mom, and she says, mom, I don't, I know you guys are paying for the wedding, but I don't want
荒谬绝伦。他会非常严肃地递给我文件，重要的工资单文件，但他会在上面贴一张便签，上面写着：“请把这些文件塞进你的屁股里好吗？”然后他还会随手画一幅小漫画，这总是让我笑得前仰后合。嗯，我只是觉得这真的好温馨，因为我，你知道的，我们回看自己的日记，读着我们写的东西，我写满了我在这一集里拍得有多开心，跟凯特在那场戏的背景里一起拍戏。太可爱了。我喜欢这个。是的，我知道。好吧。接下来我们切到帕姆的桌子，她正在跟她妈妈通电话，她说，妈妈，我不知道，我知道你们在付婚礼的费用，但我不要
orange invitations. Orange invitations. Orange invitation, Pam's mom. I mean, you know, I've had some frustrations with Pam's mom. What is happening? Add that to the list. Where are you getting married? Orange. I know. Orange. I mean, crazy. Pam, you know, her wedding color is lavender, by the way. It's not orange. I wrote that in my diary. That's not even revealed in this episode. Pam's wedding color. I wrote it down in my journal, and I was curious if that was true or if it was a character choice, and I went and I looked at the wedding photos and all my bridesmaids are in lavender. Yeah, no, that, yeah. And when I think about it, I think I have a memory of Phil Shea giving me something that had lavender on it,
橙色的请柬。橙色的请柬。橙色的请柬，帕姆的妈妈。我是说，你知道的，我对帕姆的妈妈有些意见。这算怎么回事？把这个加到清单里。你们在哪儿结婚？橙色。我懂的。橙色。我是说，太疯狂了。帕姆，你知道的，她的婚礼主题色其实是薰衣草紫。根本不是橙色。我在日记里写了。这在这一集里甚至都没有透露。帕姆的婚礼主题色。我在日记里记了下来，我很好奇那是真的还是角色的设定，我去看了婚礼照片，我所有的伴娘都穿着薰衣草紫的衣服。是的，不，那，是的。当我回想起来时，我好像还记得菲尔·谢伊给了我一件带有薰衣草紫元素的东西。
like the save the date card had a little lavender ribbon or something. And so I, it was picked for me. I didn't pick it, but it was in your brain. It was in my brain. Well, you know, poor Jim overhears this and he's like, that's it. I'm calling a travel agent. I'm going on a trip. This sort of dates our show a little bit too, because I know travel agents are still out there, but a lot of people now just go online. Yeah. Although I did use a travel agent recently for a trip and it was very helpful. I did too. Yeah. I did too when I went to Europe, but I did, you know, we did a lot of it just online. Yeah. Yeah. You can't, well, now you can compare airline prices online. Yes. Using Expedia or Orbit's not getting paid to say that. Not getting paid.
就像“请预留日期”卡片上有一条小薰衣草色的缎带什么的。所以我是，那是别人帮我选的。我没选它，但它留在了你的脑海里。它留在了我的脑海里。好吧，你知道的，可怜的吉姆无意中听到了这一切，他想，就这样吧。我要找旅行社了。我要去旅行。这其实也稍微暴露了我们节目的年代感，因为我知道旅行社现在依然存在，但现在很多人都是直接上网。对。虽然我最近为了旅行用过一次旅行社，真的很有帮助。我也用过。对。我去欧洲时也用过，但我知道，我们很多事其实也都是在网上搞定的。对。对。你不能，好吧，现在你可以在网上比价航空公司的机票了。是的。用 Expedia 或 Orbitz——我们可没收钱才这么说的。没收钱。
So now we're going to really clock into this thermostat war. It seems to mainly be between Angela and Oscar. Oscar says that he purposely gets to work early to set the thermostat at 66 degrees. What a sneaky sneak. 66. 66. I just need everyone to clock a little bit of my Angela Martin look because this is the first time you see me kind of nice and close up. Do I look tan? Because I'm tan. Are you still tan? I'm still tan. This mystic tan that lasted like three weeks. You guys, I'm so tan in this episode. Also, Kim Ferry outdid herself with this really intricate braid. That's all my actual hair. Look at the back. It's like a bun, but it's like a braid that goes like zigzags back and forth. So she's really, she really went for it. In the cold open, I have a
所以现在我们要真正关注一下这场恒温器大战了。这似乎主要是安吉拉和奥斯卡之间的矛盾。奥斯卡说他故意早点去公司，把恒温器调到 66 度。真是一个偷偷摸摸的小机灵鬼。66度。66度。我需要大家注意一下我安吉拉·马丁的造型，因为这是你第一次近距离看到我这个样子。我看起来晒黑了吗？因为我晒黑了。你还晒着呢？我还在呢。这个神秘喷雾美黑效果持续了大约三周。你们大家，我在这一集里晒得太黑了。另外，金·费里（Kim Ferry）用这个非常复杂的辫子超越了她自己。那全是我自己的头发。看后面。它就像一个发髻，但又像是一条前后呈“之”字形交错的辫子。所以她真的很用心，她全力以赴了。在冷场开场白中，我有一个
different outfit on, different hair. Different look. Different look. Different day. Different day. But in the main episode of Dwight's speech, I'm incredibly tan and I have this fantastic Kim Ferry braid. Well, we had a fan question from David Hirtweck. What was the actual temperature in the office area when we were filming? Freezing. Probably like 65. I was going to say 64, 65 degrees. Yeah. It was very, very cold. We kept it very, very cold, mostly for Steve who runs hot and he would have to wear the suits. And, and I mean, all the guys actually were always in suits and the lights do like warm up the stage, but they cranked the air down so the guys wouldn't get sweaty in their suits. But the gals were in these little silk blouses and skirts and we all
不同的穿搭，不同的发型。不同的造型。不同的面貌。不同的一天。不同的一天。但在主集《德怀特的演讲》中，我晒得超级黑，而且梳着这个绝妙的金·费里式编发。好吧，我们有一个来自大卫·赫特韦克的粉丝提问。我们拍摄时办公区实际的温度是多少？冰冷。大概 65 度左右。我本来想说 64、65 度。对。非常非常冷。我们把它开得非常非常冷，主要是为了史蒂夫，他比较怕热，而且他得穿西装。而且，我是说，其实所有的男生一直都穿着西装，灯光确实会让舞台变暖，但他们把空调开到最低，这样男士们穿西装就不会流汗了。但女生们穿着这些小丝绸衬衫和裙子，我们全都
froze. Yeah. So I would wear Ugg boots under my desk. We all had little heaters. I sometimes even had a blanket over my legs. I had a blanket and a heater and I would like sit at my desk, like huddled under my desk, trying to stay warm. All right. So now we move into the conference room and Michael is ready to start giving Dwight some speech training. Yes. He says, what is the difference between a salesman and a saleswoman? Vagina. Vagina. And Michael is like, oh, yes, congratulations Dwight. That's the difference between a man and a woman. I love Dwight goes, but I'm right. Yeah. But I'm right. Right. But then Michael says, no, the difference is boobs. That's what he wants him to open his speech with. It makes you wonder how Michael's speech went
冻僵了。对。所以我会在办公桌底下穿UGG雪地靴。我们都有小暖风机。我有时甚至会在腿上盖条毯子。我有一条毯子和一个暖风机，然后我就会坐在办公桌前，像这样缩在桌子底下，试图保持暖和。好吧。所以现在我们来到会议室，迈克尔准备开始对德怀特进行一些演讲培训。是的。他说，男推销员和女推销员有什么区别？阴道。阴道。然后迈克尔就说，哦，是的，恭喜你，德怀特。这就是男人和女人的区别。我喜欢德怀特说，但我说得对啊。对。但我说得对。对。但接着迈克尔说，不，区别是胸部。这就是他想让他用来作为演讲开场白的内容。这让人不禁好奇迈克尔的演讲是怎么进行的
those two years in a row. How it really went. How it really went. Yeah. Yeah. Because Dwight says, can I just have a copy of your speech? And Michael's like, no, no, they'd remember. Yeah. It's legendary. I couldn't possibly let you read parts of my speech. It killed. It killed. And then Michael gives Dwight some advice. He's like, it doesn't really matter what you say as long as people care about what you're saying. Uh-huh. And he's going to show him an example of that. Yes. Please tell us the example. Okay. Well, he runs out into the bullpen and he says that, you know, they done so well this quarter that corporate is going to give everyone a thousand dollar bonus. Everyone. Everyone. I mean, people are thrilled. It's so excited. Stanley gets right on the phone
连续两年都是那样。到底是怎么进行的。到底是怎么进行的。对。对。因为德怀特说，我能要一份你的演讲稿副本吗？迈克尔却说，不，不，他们会记住的。对。那可是个传奇。我绝对不可能让你读我演讲的一部分。那效果绝了。太绝了。然后迈克尔给德怀特一些建议。他说，其实你说什么并不重要，只要大家在意你在说什么就行。嗯哼。他要向他展示一个这样的例子。是的。请给我们讲讲这个例子。好吧。然后他跑进大办公区，他说，你知道的，他们这个季度干得太出色了，公司决定给每个人发一千美元的奖金。每个人。每个人。我是说，大家简直欣喜若狂。太兴奋了。斯坦利立刻拿起电话
and tells his wife to order the new curtains. The wallpaper. Oh, it's wallpaper. Yes. Yeah. He's like, go ahead, wallpaper the ceiling if you want to. Amazing. So they go back into the conference room and Dwight's like, oh my God, that's amazing. And Michael's like, what? It's not true. I was just talking. But in that moment, I had him. I had him. I had him. Oh my God. So Dwight tries it. Dwight goes out into the bullpen. This is so funny. This scene made me laugh so hard. So hard. It made me laugh on the day. I remember shooting this. The thing that made me laugh on the day is Kelly's line, but I'll get to that. Yeah. You mean just Mindy Mindy. We still have full Mindy. Dwight announces that there has been a major car accident on the interstate.
告诉他的妻子去订购新窗帘。壁纸。哦，是壁纸。是的。对。他当时说，去吧，如果你想的话，把天花板也贴上壁纸。太棒了。所以他们回到会议室，德怀特就说，哦天哪，这太棒了。迈克尔就说，什么？这不是真的。我只是随便说说。但在那一刻，我拿捏住他了。我拿捏住他了。我拿捏住他了。哦天哪。所以德怀特也试了一下。德怀特跑去了大办公区。这太搞笑了。这场戏把我笑得前仰后合。笑死我了。拍摄当天的我就笑得很厉害。让我大笑不已的台词是凯莉的那句，不过我会说到那点的。对。你是说明迪，明迪。我们依然拥有完整的明迪。德怀特宣布州际公路上发生了一起重大车祸。
Major car slid off the road into the railing. People were injured. Terrible. And Pam says, did we know anyone in the accident? And he says, Brad Pitt, Brad Pitt and Mindy asks, did he die? And he's like, he'll never act again. No, but he'll never act again. And then he goes, oh, also there's no bonuses. And the branch is closing. And then she's like, this is because of Jen Aniston. It's karma. And we're like, wait, and we're like, are we out of jobs? Like what is happening? Insane. I remember that. I remember shooting on that day. That was a really hard one to get through. And it was a complete joy to watch. All right. So Michael says, everybody go in the conference room. Just go in the conference room. He's going to teach
重大车祸，车子滑出路面撞上了护栏。有人受伤了。太惨了。帕姆说，我们认识车祸里的人吗？他说，布拉德·皮特，布拉德·皮特。明迪问，他死了吗？然后他说，他再也不会演戏了。不，但他再以后都不能演戏了。然后他说，哦，对了，也没有奖金了。而且分公司要倒闭了。然后她说，这是因为詹妮弗·安妮斯顿。这是因果报应。然后我们就想，等等，然后我们就想，我们失业了吗？到底怎么回事。太疯狂了。我记得那个。我记得拍摄那一天的情景。那一集真的是很难拍过去的一集。而且看的时候绝对是一种享受。好吧。所以迈克尔说，大家全部进会议室。直接进会议室。他要教
everyone how to give a speech. Pam says, Pam has this line like toastmasters. And Michael says, Pam, I'm public speaking. Stop public interrupting me. I don't think that's a gift, but it should be. I did a search to see if there is a gift of someone of Michael saying, I'm public speaking. Stop public interrupting me. Am I wrong? Am I wrong? There's also deleted scene. Please, you guys, if you have a chance, Phyllis stands up in the conference room and sort of shares. And it is absolutely amazing. What does she share? I remember she had a hard time getting through it when we were cracking up. Michael wants everyone to get up and sort of say a toast. Phyllis gets up and she's like, well, you know, I'm having one of the
大家怎么做演讲。帕姆说，帕姆有这样一句台词，比如“头马俱乐部”（Toastmasters）。迈克尔说，帕姆，我在公开演讲。请停止公开打断我。我不认为那是个梗，但它应该是个梗。我搜了一下，看有没有人做过迈克尔说“我在公开演讲。请停止公开打断我”这个动图。我错了吗？我错了吗？还有一个被删掉的片段。求求你们了，各位，如果有机会的话，菲莉丝在会议室里站起来分享了一些内容。那绝对是太棒了。她分享了什么？我记得当我们在狂笑时，她很难把那段演完。迈克尔希望每个人都站起来发表一下祝酒词。菲莉丝站起来说，嗯，你知道的，我正经历着我一生中
best years of my life. I'm in a relationship. I've met a nice person and I really thought that that part of my life was over for me, that that wasn't going to happen. And I'm not going to lie. I've had some really dark thoughts. She goes down this road and Michael's like, and really, really just brings the room totally down, but really earnest. And Michael's like, oh, okay, all right, just sit down. Well, Jim gets up in the conference room and announces he's going on a trip and he would like some suggestions on where to go. So Kevin suggests he go to hedonism. He says, it's like club med, but everything is naked. I did not Google that. I didn't want to know. Did you? I did. Oh my God. I did. You did? I did. Is it a real thing? It is a real resort in Jamaica.
最好的几年之一。我在谈恋爱。我遇到了一个很好的人，我真的以为我生活中的那个部分对我来说已经结束了，那种事不会再发生了。而且我不会撒谎。我曾有过一些非常黑暗的想法。她顺着这个思路说下去，而迈克尔就觉得，真的是，把整个房间的氛围完全拉低了，但又极其真诚。迈克尔就说，哦，好吧，行了，快坐下吧。好吧，吉姆在会议室里站起来，宣布他要去旅行，他想征求一些关于去哪里的建议。于是凯文建议他去享乐主义度假村（Hedonism）。他说，这就像地中海俱乐部，但所有人都是一丝不挂的。我可没有谷歌搜索那个。我不想知道。你搜了吗？我搜了。哦天哪。我搜了。你搜了？我搜了。那是真的吗？那是位于牙买加的一个真实度假村。
And everyone's naked? Yep. Well, okay, their website describes it as, quote, a lifestyle friendly clothing optional resort. Also described as the sexiest place on earth where you can be as mild or wild as you like. What does that mean? Okay, so here's the deal. I really looked into it. So there are clothing optional sections of the resort and then there are nude sections. So like you could be going down the buffet. That you cannot do. Handcakes, scrambled eggs. No, for health reasons, you must wear a cover up in the lobby and around food. Well, thank you for that. But if you're in the nude pool or the nude beach, you have to be nude. But if you're in the clothing optional part, you can wear sort of the suggestion is like,
而且每个人都一丝不挂？没错。好吧，好吧，他们的网站将其描述为，引述，“一个生活方式友好、服装可选的度假村。”也被描述为地球上最性感的地方，在那里你可以像你喜欢的那样温和或狂野。那是什么意思？好吧，事情是这样的。我真的深入了解了一下。度假村里有服装可选的区域，还有全裸的区域。所以，比如说你可以在去吃自助餐的路上。那可不行。煎饼，炒蛋。不，出于健康考虑，你在大厅和食物周围必须穿遮盖物。好吧，谢谢你提供这个。但如果你在裸体泳池或裸体海滩，你就必须一丝不挂。但如果你在服装可选的区域，你可以穿，建议是，
you know, go sexy. You wear a little something. But here was one thing I found interesting. If you enter a nude area, you've got a 10 minute grace period to disrobe. And they're like, then you got to get out. You're not here to look see, look see. That's right. We're going to join us out to take off your stuff. But there's more. You thought there wasn't, but there is no, I actually figured you had something else coming. I'm cringing. I'm waiting. They have a playroom. Oh, God, for couples, single women and invited single men. Oh, Lord. So open from 10 30pm to 3am. You go wrestle with your friends. I don't know. Most people who stay at the resorts are couples. But they do have single person rates available.
你知道的，穿性感一点。穿一点点衣服。但有一件事我觉得很有趣。如果你进入裸体区域，你会有 10 分钟的宽限期来脱衣服。他们会说，然后你就得脱光。你来这里可不是为了走马观花、东张西望的。没错。我们要加入我们，脱掉你的东西。但还有更多。你以为没有了，其实有。不，我其实猜到你还有别的料。我都起鸡皮疙瘩了。我在等着呢。他们有一个游戏室。哦，天哪，专为情侣、单身女性和受邀的单身男性准备的。哦，天哪。所以从晚上 10 点半开放到凌晨 3 点。你去和你的朋友摔跤吧。我不知道。住在度假村里的大多数人都是情侣。但他们确实提供单人价格。
A few more facts. There is no tipping allowed. Who are you tipping? Your weight staff, but it's all inclusive. Oh, so I mean, I think that that is an important thing to know because where would you put the money? Oh, you're naked. You're naked. So don't, don't let it stress you out. There's no tipping allowed. Yeah. Don't worry about where you're carrying the extra cash. Yeah. Not a problem. One of the frequently asked questions is, are there irons and ironing boards? For what? I don't know. But the answer is yes. So yes, they do have irons and ironing boards. So also you can renew your vows there. Okay. All right. Toby suggests that Jim go to Amsterdam. He says he went there after his
再多几个事实。这里不允许给小费。你要给谁小费？你的服务员，但这里是一价全包的。哦，所以，我觉得这是一个重要的信息，因为你要把钱藏在哪儿？哦，你是光着身子的。你是光着身子的。所以别，别给自己增添压力。这里不允许给小费。对。不用担心你把多余的现金带在哪儿。对。这不是问题。常见问题之一是，那里有熨斗和熨衣板吗？为了什么？我不知道。但答案是有。所以是的，它们确实有熨斗和熨衣板。另外，你还可以在那里重温誓言。好吧。好吧。托比建议吉姆去阿姆斯特丹。他说他在
divorce for a week or maybe a month. He can't remember Toby. Creed says he should go to Hong Kong. Creed also calls John Jimmy. And I feel like you can see John about to break. He's like, Jimmy. And I swear, John has this like, he's kind of got this side smile. Well, at nine minutes, 29 seconds, Creed has a talking head. For anyone wondering, Creed is speaking Mandarin. Yeah. And he says, hello, my Chinese friends. That's what he's saying in Mandarin. I reached out to Creed. Yeah. Because we had a fan question from KKPL Watson. He said, at various times, Creed has spoken Japanese and Chinese on the show. Does he really speak either? So I texted Creed. Oh, I can't wait. What was his response?
离婚后去那里呆了一周或者可能是一个月。他不记得了，托比。克里德说他应该去香港。克里德还叫吉姆“吉米”。我觉得你能看出吉姆快要憋不住笑场了。他说，“吉米”。我发誓，吉姆当时脸上有一种，他脸上带着这种侧面微笑。好吧，在 9 分钟 29 秒的时候，克里德有一个单人访谈。对于任何想知道的人，克里德说的是普通话。对。他说，你好，我的中国朋友们。他在普通话里说的是这个。我联系了克里德。对。因为我们有一个来自 KKPL Watson 的粉丝提问。他说，克里德在剧中曾多次说日语和汉语。他真的会说其中任何一种吗？所以我给克里德发了短信。哦，我等不及了。他的回应是什么？
Here's what he said. Did he say, who are you? No. But again, I wasn't sure. He said, when I was in Germany in 1964, I conversed in a rudimentary fashion because I'd studied a year in college. But he said he hasn't used it since. He says he does not speak Japanese or Mandarin or Cantonese, which is actually the language they speak in Hong Kong, mostly not Mandarin. But he said, I do have a made up language that I've been trying to get accepted. That I believe. But he's been meeting resistance. And he used it during his stint as manager for that week at Dunder Mifflin. Oh my God. This is Creed, guys. This is Creed. All right. At nine minutes, 57 seconds, my character smiles. This doesn't happen very often. And Jenna, I did one of our little
他是这么说的。他说，“你是谁”吗？没有。不过话说回来，我也不确定。他说，当我在 1964 年在德国时，我用一种很粗浅的方式进行交流，因为我在大学里学过一年。但他说他从那以后就没再用过了。他说他不会说日语、普通话或粤语，而粤语实际上是他们在香港主要说的语言，而不是普通话。但他却说，我确实有一种自创的语言，我一直在努力让它被接受。这个我信。但他的努力遭到了阻力。他在邓德米夫林当了一周经理的那段时间里，就用过它。哦，天哪。这就是克里德，伙计们。这就是克里德。好吧，在 9 分钟 57 秒的时候，我的角色笑了。这可不常发生。而詹娜，我做了我们那种书呆子式的精算师举动，我给这个微笑或这个小瞬间编造了一个背景故事。所以这不是剧本里写好的。但在会议室里，德怀特接下来要为我们进行他的演讲。他拿着他的记事卡，对吧？然后我只是给自己编造了这样一个背景故事，即他可能在我的面前练习过这个，我们一起排练过。所以当他站上去时，我真的满面春风，我环顾四周以确认，大家都在看吗？因为我真的为他感到骄傲。对。所以我脑子里就有这么个小心思。我没有告诉任何人。但我们的摄像师兰德尔和马特拍下了这一幕，它最终被剪进了正片。哦。他们经常这样做。兰德尔和马特会捕捉到我们在背景中做出的这些不在剧本里的微小瞬间。他们非常擅长发现这些瞬间，并确保每个人都能看到它们。我喜欢我们所有人自始至终都如此投入于我们的角色，以及我们的角色会对某个瞬间或某个故事做出什么反应，以至于即使我们没有受到导演指导，或者不认为摄像机正对着我们，我们也会留在角色中并做出即兴反应。对。这就是进入正片的其中一个例子。对。我记得马特说：“安吉，我看到你在做什么了。我记下了。”我拍下来了。每当他们注意到我们的小选择时，总是觉得那么有趣。对。啊。我太喜欢了。对。好吧，然后我们来到吉姆和德怀特的办公桌，安吉拉。德怀特一直在谈论，他要去新西兰。
dorky actuary things where I gave myself a backstory for this little smile or this little moment. So it wasn't scripted. But in the conference room, Dwight is going to now do his speech for us. He has his note cards, right? And I just sort of gave myself this backstory that he had probably practiced this in front of me, that we had worked on it together. And so I just really beam as he gets up there and I look around to make sure, is everyone watching? Because I'm really proud of him. Yeah. So I just had this little thing I gave myself. I didn't tell anyone. But Randall and Matt, our camera operators, they caught it and it made it in. Oh. And they would often do that. Randall and Matt would sort of catch these little moments that we did in the background that weren't part
我不知道。他告诉吉姆他应该去新西兰，走《指环王》的徒步路线。好吧。我完全听不懂那些。你听懂了吗？我当然听懂了。所以吉姆，你懂那些东西是什么意思。我懂所有那些意思，詹娜。但吉姆就像是，德怀特，你打算去哪儿，如果你能去任何地方的话，德怀特就说，我可以去任何地方，而且我也会去。对。但他想去的地方之一就是新西兰，因为他想走《指环王》到魔多的徒步路线。嗯哼。我不知道那是什么。那是个地方吗？魔多。魔多是一座城堡吗？那是个地方。它是城堡，还是像地底下藏在石头里的某种东西？那是个地方。它是一个村庄吗？魔多是索伦所在的地方。对。所以我们，
of the script. And they were so great about sort of finding those moments and making sure that everyone saw them. I just like that all of us all the time, we were so invested in our characters and how our character would react to a moment or to a story that even if we hadn't been directed or didn't think the camera was on us, we would stay in our characters and react in the moment. Yeah. And that's an example of one of those that made it in. Yeah. And I remember Matt saying, Ang, I see what you're doing. I'm going to clock it. I caught it. That was always so fun when they would notice our little choices. Yeah. Aw. I love that. Yeah. Well, then we go to Jim and Dwight's desks, Angela. And Dwight is talking all about the, he's going to go to New Zealand.
抱歉，索伦是什么？索伦，索伦之眼。那是某种东西还是一个人？我不知道该怎么形容它。那是纯粹的邪恶。你怎么能不形容，你怎么形容索伦之眼？它就像是一个，它就像是一个邪恶的灵魂。但它不是一个人。萨姆，我该怎么解释索伦之眼？我觉得它，它曾经是一个人。它曾经是一个人，而且他正在恢复他的力量。如果他得到了魔戒，那他就能再次成为一个人。然后他就能完全完整，并把纯粹的地狱统治带到这片土地的各处。所以你很难向我解释它，这就是为什么我不想看它的原因。好吧，我不是。因为它太复杂了。我对《指环王》没有那么了解。好吧，好吧。所以，那个，但我确实知道通往魔多的路以及。
I don't know. He tells Jim he should go to New Zealand and walk the Lord of the Rings trail. Okay. I did not understand any of that. Did you understand that? Of course I did. So Jim, you knew what all that stuff meant. I knew what all of it meant, Jenna. But Jim is like, Dwight, where would you, if you could go anywhere and Dwight was like, I can go anywhere and I will. Yeah. But one of the places he would like to go is New Zealand because he wants to walk the Lord of the Rings trail to Modor. Uh-huh. I don't know what that is. Is that a place? Modor. Modor is a castle? It's a place. Is it a castle or is it like something hidden under a rock in the ground? It's a place. Is it a village? Modor is where Sauron is. Yeah. So we're,
你为什么想去那里？为什么人们试图去魔多或者不想去魔多？你才不想去那儿呢。为什么，那为什么德怀特想去那里？我是说，那里有熔岩原和所有这种疯狂的景色。然后还要徒步末日火山。我觉得德怀特是个超级《指环王》迷。他基本上想成为《指环王》里的一员。他想经历这段旅程和冒险。我问你个问题，但它是新西兰拍摄的，而且景色美极了。所以我很想去。是不是，他们叫魔戒之王（Lords of the Rings），因为他们的工作就是不让戒指落入索伦之眼手里？哦，天哪。还是因为他们想把戒指带给他？不。这样他就又变成一个普通人了？不。首先，你是故意把它名字叫错的吗？
sorry, what is Sauron? Sauron, the Eye of Sauron. Is that a thing or a person? I don't know how to describe it. It's pure evil. How can you not describe, how do you describe the Eye of Sauron? It's like, it's like a, it's like an evil spirit. But it's not a person. Sam, how do I explain Eye of Sauron? I think it was, it was a person. It was a person and he's gaining his power back. If he gets to the ring, then he can be a person again. Then he can be fully complete and he will reign pure hell all over the land. So your difficulty and explaining it to me is why I don't like to watch it. Well, I'm not. Because it's like so convoluted. I'm not as versed in Lord of the Rings. Okay, all right. So that, but I do know that the trail to Modor and.
不，我没有。Swarzen（索伦）。Swarzen。Swarzen。Swarzen。这就像卡尔那集重演了一样。好吧。继续。继续。11 分钟 3 秒。吉姆对德怀特搞了个恶作剧。对。没有帕姆。对。这是好一阵子以来的头一次。通常他们是一起搞恶作剧的。这是一个很棒的恶作剧。他们是一伙的。对。这是一个吉姆的个人恶作剧。对。他受够了德怀特在他面前显摆，好像他马上就要成为年度销售员似的。吉姆决定，你知道吗？我来给你点建议。我大学里主修的是演讲专业，这完全是假的。假的。假的。然后他说，你必须挥舞手臂，捶击拳头。他给了他一份墨索里尼的演讲稿。是的。他说，这里有一些，这里有一些
Why would you want to go there? Why are people trying to go to Modor or not trying to go to Modor? You don't want to go there. Why, so why does Dwight want to go there? I mean, there's like lava fields and all this kind of craziness. And then hike Mount Doom. I think Dwight is like a huge Lord of the Rings fan. He basically wants to be one of the Lord of the Rings. He wants to be on this journey and adventure. Let me ask you this, but it's filmed in New Zealand and it's gorgeous. So I would love to go. Is, are they the Lords of the Rings because it's their job to keep the rings from the Eye of Swarzen? Oh, good God. Or because they want to get the ring to him. No. So he turns into a regular person again. No. First of all, are you trying to say it wrong?
可能会对你的演讲有帮助的东西。我来帮帮你。我在红迪网（Reddit）上发现，红迪网上有一个办公室粉丝，那个人的签名是“下划线可替代的下划线男”（_fungible_man）。好吧。他说，他查了一下，这是墨索里尼 1914 年 12 月 13 日在帕尔马发表的一段演讲的释义，当时该演讲倡导意大利参加反对德国的第一次世界大战。哇。唯有鲜血才能推动历史的车轮。现在，我觉得里面还夹杂了一些其他著名独裁者的名言。确实如此。这看起来像是个大杂烩。主要还是墨索里尼，我相信。对。好吧，当德怀特和迈克尔离开时，安吉拉大喊，祝你好运，德怀特。我知道。好吧，在 12 分钟时，当镜头切回会计部的安吉拉时，奥斯卡把外套披在肩膀上
No, I don't. Swarzen. Swarzen. Swarzen. Swarzen. This is like Carl all over again. Okay. Moving on. Moving on. 11 minutes, three seconds. Jim does a prank on Dwight. Yeah. Without Pam. Yeah. This is one of the first in a while. Normally they do pranks together. This is a good good prank. They're in cahoots. Yeah. This is a Jim solo prank. Yeah. He's like had it with Dwight sort of shoving this in his face that he's like going to be like the salesman of the year. And Jim decides, you know what? I'll give you advice. I was a speech major in college, which is totally not true. Not true. Not true. And he's like, you've got to wave your arms and pound your fist. And he gives them a copy of Mussolini's speech. Yes. He says, here are some, here are some things
就像他很冷一样，凯文则在往手上吹气。但是记住，不是奥斯卡说过他喜欢冷吗？那是假装很冷。我不知道，因为凯文还有一个单人访谈，说他去把温度调到了 69 度。没错。好吧，所以我们来到会议室，有帕姆、凯莉和瑞恩坐在一起处理帕姆的“请预留日期”卡片。所以我们发现了什么。她的婚礼将在 6 月 10 日举行。我们从游艇派对那一集就已经知道了，招待会在退伍军人协会（VA）举行。对。帕姆说那里比你想的要好。对。我们发现她邀请了吉姆。对。你们都觉得，什么？这里有一个超棒的被删减片段。这真的就是我喜欢称之为“瑞恩式的傲慢”的开端。这将在本集稍后
that might help you in your speech. I'm going to help you out. I found on Reddit, there's an office fan on Reddit, and the person's sign is the underscore fungible underscore man. Okay. And he said, he looked it up in its paraphrase from a speech Mussolini gave in Parma on December 13th, 1914, advocating for Italy to enter into World War One against Germany. Wow. Blood alone moves the wheels of history. Now, I think there are some other famous dictators quotes peppered in as well. It is. It seems like it's a hodgepodge. Mostly Mussolini, I believe. Yeah. Well, when Dwight leaves with Michael, Angela shouts, the very best of luck to you Dwight. I know. Well, at 12 minutes, when it pans back to Angela at accounting, Oscar has his coat over his shoulders
真正全面爆发。有一个被删减的片段，就在你们走进会议室去装请柬之前，你在前台接待处，瑞恩走了进来，你就说，哦，你拿到我的邮票了吗？然后他说，对。他把它们递给你，然后你说，我想要的是“爱”系列邮票，你知道的，“爱”系列邮票。对。然后他说，对，我没有，我不知道。我没找到。我只给你买普通邮票了。然后你就说，哦。然后他接着说，这很重要吗？然后你就说，对，其实也不太重要。然后他走开说，我也觉得不重要。瑞恩式的傲慢。我知道。哇。好吧。接下来德怀特和迈克尔到达了会议中心。伙计们，太巨大了。太疯狂了。到处都是人。这是一个庞大的
like he's cold and Kevin is blowing on his hands. But remember, wasn't it Oscar who says he likes the cold? It was pretending to be cold. I don't know because also Kevin has a talking head that says he goes and puts it to 69. Exactly. All right. So we move into the conference room and we have Pam, Kelly and Ryan sitting addressing Pam save the date cards. So here's what we find out. Her wedding is going to be June 10th. We already knew that from the booze cruise and the reception is going to be at the VA. Yeah. Pam says it's nicer than you think. Yeah. And we find out she is inviting Jim. Yeah. You're all like, what? There is a great deleted scene. And it is really the beginning of what I like to call Ryan sass. That's going to really kick into effect later
会展中心，比迈克尔记忆中的要大得多。对。他们走过去时放的是什么音乐？是“准备好迎接这一切了吗？”（Y'all ready for this?）对。放吧。放吧，萨姆。“准备好迎接这一切了吗？”好吧。我们还在看音乐录影带。我们在看音乐录影带。里面有很多键盘乐器。是 2 Unlimited 乐队唱的。那是那个乐队。我必须说那首歌挺让人振奋的。超级洗脑。他们在很多体育赛事上都会放这首歌。确实。或者在年度销售员颁奖典礼上。在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿。斯克兰顿。没错。所以我是说德怀特有点开始恐慌了。他确实在恐慌。他有点轻微的恐慌发作。而办公室里的安吉拉在装病。我知道。她一直在咳嗽和吸鼻子。突然之间，她说她
in this episode. There's a deleted scene where right before you go into the conference room to assemble your invites, you're at front reception and Ryan comes in and you're like, oh, did you get my stamps? And he's like, yeah. And he hands them to you and you're like, I wanted the love stamps, you know, the love stamps. Yeah. And he goes, yeah, I didn't, I don't know. I didn't find them. I just got you the regular ones. And you're like, oh. And then he's like, does it matter? And you're like, yeah, it doesn't really matter. And he goes, I didn't think so. Ryan sass. I know. Wow. All right. So next Dwight and Michael arrive at the convention center. You guys, it's huge. It's insane. It's full of people. It's an enormous
感觉身体不舒服。她需要回家。对。顺便说一句，皮肤依然晒得很黑。而且镜头里。一点也不苍白。一点也不苍白。然后他们叫到了德怀特的名字。而他，他怯场了。他怯场了。他怯场了。他上不去台。所以迈克尔冲上了舞台。我们会把这个消音的。这是我在笔记里写的内容。他彻底搞砸了。对。他真的是搞砸了。所以在这一切发生期间，我当然在寻找肯特跟我说过的那些人体模型。我就想，模型在哪儿呢？我没注意到有什么人体模型。然而，在 14 分钟 19 秒时，有一个观众镜头的特写。而且，我不知道该怎么形容它。它像是翻转了。它就像是，它是一个镜像。如果你看其他每一个镜头里的名牌，它们都在每个人衬衫的右侧。
convention way bigger than Michael remembers. Right. And what is playing as they walk through? It's y'all ready for this? Yeah. Play it. Play it, Sam. Y'all ready for this? Okay. We're also watching the music video. We're watching the music video. It's a lot of keyboard. It's by Two Unlimited. That's the band. And I have to say that song kind of pumps you up. Super catchy. They play it at a lot of sporting events. They do. Or salesmen of the year. In Scranton, Pennsylvania. Scranton. That's right. So I mean Dwight kind of starts panicking. He is. He's having a minor panic. He's having a minor panic attack. And Angela back in the office is pretending to be sick. I know. She's coughing and sniffling. All of a sudden, she says she's
但在这一镜头中，它们突然出现在了左侧，并且名字都是反着写的。这到底是怎么回事？这到底是怎么回事？什么？我们还有一个粉丝提问。有两个人问了这个。卢克·马斯洛（Luke Maslow）和斯库特·维诺迈尔（Scoot Venonmire）都问了迈克尔的演讲有多少是即兴发挥的。我相信他确实即兴发挥了不少。不过，我有非常深刻的记忆。你知道他模仿迈克尔·温斯洛（Michael Winslow）发出各种不同声音的那段吗？就是从这开始的。对。迈克尔·温斯洛是《警察学校》电影里的一位著名演员，他能发出所有这些真正不可思议、听起来超级逼真的音效。所以迈克尔在尽他最大努力模仿迈克尔·温斯洛。我从剧本围读时就记得那段效果炸裂。所以我觉得那
feeling under the weather. She needs to go home. Yeah. And by the way, still very tan. And a shot. Not pale. Not pale at all. So they called Dwight's name. And he, he chokes. He chokes. He chokes. He can't go up. So Michael runs up on stage. And we'll bleep this out. This is what I wrote in my note. He shits the bed. Yeah. He really does. So during all of this, of course, I'm trying to look for the dummies that Kent told me about. I'm like, where are the dummies? I did not notice any dummies. However, at 14 minutes, 19 seconds, there is a shot of the audience. And it is, I don't know how to describe it. It's like flipped. It's like, it's a mirror image. If you look at the name tags in every other shot, they are on the right side of everyone's shirts.
至少在剧本里是写好了的。安吉拉，史蒂夫在表演他那部分的时候你在场吗？比如，你有什么记忆吗？我在后台等着上场。好吧。所以我当时在场。在某些镜头中，他们会安排我在那儿，以防万一。我记得观众，那些群众演员，那 400 名群众演员一直被史蒂夫逗乐。导演不得不告诉他们，你们不能笑。哦，对。你们不能笑。你们不能有反应。真的吗？你们得表现得很讨厌这个。台下必须鸦雀无声。所以我确实记得这一点。哦，那太有趣了。好吧，最后德怀特冲上了舞台，对吧？对，他鼓起了勇气。他拿出他的演讲稿。他开始捶击拳头。我们有几个粉丝提问。玛丽·凯·琼斯（Mary Kay Jones）和莎拉·海兰（Sarah Highland）问，
But in this shot, they're suddenly on the left side and the names are written backwards. What is happening? What is happening? What? We also had a fan question. Two people asked this. Luke Maslow and Scoot Venonmire both asked how much of Michael's speech was improvised. I believe he did improvise quite a bit. However, I have a very strong memory. You know that part when he does Michael Winslow and he does all the different like sounds? This is a part starting. Yeah. Michael Winslow was this famous actor from the police academy movies who could do all of these truly incredible sound effects that sounded super real. And so Michael's trying to do his best Michael Winslow impression. I remember from the table read that that killed. So I feel like that
雷恩拍那段演讲拍了多少次？所以我去问了雷恩，他说他觉得大概拍了四五次左右。肯特告诉我，在第一条时，背景里的观众直接疯狂了，就像在起哄尖叫一样。群众演员，伙计们，坐在那里的那 400 个人。是的。而且肯特说那简直堪称惊艳。那是极其精彩的一瞬间。但问题是格雷格和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔（Charles McDougal）非常希望观众的反应是一个循序渐进的过程。确实如此。观众对德怀特的反应有点太快了。他们希望观众对德怀特到底能不能成功感到不确定。对。大家对此作何反应？所以肯特说第一条基本上没法用。雷恩说他记得有一次他
was at least in that was scripted. Were you there for when Steve was doing his portion at all, Angela? Like, do you have a memory? I was waiting to go on. Okay. So I was there. And some takes, they would have, they just had me there just in case. And I remember that the audience, the extras, the 400 extras kept getting tickled at Steve. And they had to tell them, you can't laugh. Oh, yeah. You can't laugh. You can't react. Really? You have to hate this. It has to be crickets. So I do remember that. Oh, that's very interesting. Well, finally Dwight runs up on stage, right? Yeah, he gets his courage. He gets out his speech. He starts pounding his fists. And we had a few fan questions. Mary Kay Jones and Sarah Highland asked,
脱离了剧本，进行了即兴发挥。但随后他被指导不要再那样做了，他们真的很希望他严格按照剧本演。我们有一个来自卡拉·阿登（Kayla Ardent）的粉丝提问，雷恩手里的那张纸上真的写了演讲稿吗？雷恩说，是的。他说他确实写了，因为他觉得他的角色会这么做。安吉拉，我们之前聊过你当时在场，原因就在于此，因为你正在背景里拍摄这场演讲。我在为他录像。头上戴着那顶小帽子。我在录像。所以德怀特的演讲开始受到欢迎，而迈克尔受不了了。对。迈克尔就想，哦天哪，他们喜欢他。他显然无法接受德怀特迎来高光时刻。他离开了，当他离开时，他从我扮演的角色身边走过，我当时
how many times did it take for Rain to get through that speech? So I asked Rain, and he said that he thinks he did it about four or five times. Kent told me that on the first take, the background went absolutely wild, like hooting and hollering. The extras, guys, the 400 people sitting there. Yes. And Kent said it was kind of phenomenal. It was this amazing moment. But the problem was that Greg and Charles McDougal really wanted a buildup of the crowd reaction. They did. That the crowd was kind of too instantly with Dwight. They wanted it for the audience to be unsure whether Dwight was going to be a hit or not. Yes. How is everyone taking this in? So Kent said the first take was pretty unusable. Rain said that he remembers at one point he went
藏在人群中，拍摄德怀特。我戴着帽子。所以你们知道之前关于情人节那集里你的头发有过很多讨论吧？对。嗯，服装部和我关于这顶帽子进行了长时间的讨论，因为它是非常针对镜头的。我必须看起来像是在隐姓埋名，但你们又必须能看到我的脸。所以剧本里写了你要戴帽子吗，然后服装部才想出了各种帽子的选择？是的。对。所以我们大概有，我不知道，五六种帽子的选择，我都得试戴一下，他们拍下了我戴着帽子的照片，然后拿给，你知道的，所有相关人员看。然后还有，比如在拍摄当天我有那顶帽子，还有另外一顶帽子，而那顶能更好地露出我的脸。好吧。所以他们就选了那顶。它的帽檐没有那么大。
off script, and he improvised. But then he was directed not to do that again, that they really wanted him to stick to the script. And we had a fan question from Kayla Ardent, did Rain actually have the speech written on that paper? And Rain said, yes. He said he did because he thought his character would. Angela, we've talked about that you were there, and here's why, because you're taping the speech in the background. I'm filming it for him. With your little hat on. I'm filming it. So Dwight's speech starts to catch on, and Michael can't take it. Yeah. Michael's like, oh my god, they like him. He clearly can't handle Dwight having a moment of success. He leaves, and as he leaves, he walks past my character, kind of hidden in
所以那就是我们最后选定的帽子。我喜欢她去录制同伴演讲的那个小细节。我也是。她太为他们骄傲了。你知道，他们本来是被设定为那种搞笑关系的，但他们其实有着非常好的关系。他们彼此支持。他们显然很在乎彼此。正是这样的时刻，让它不仅仅是一个笑话。这不仅仅是一段搞笑的关系。这些时刻让这段感情落地生根，变得真实。听着，德怀特和安吉拉对我来说非常合乎情理。是的。他们确实如此，就像我读到吉姆和帕姆的感情时，觉得他们合乎情理一样。很显然，他们会经历一些起起伏伏，但他们注定是要在一起的。
the crowd, filming Dwight. And I'm wearing a hat. So you know how there was a big conversation about your hair in Valentine's? Yeah. Well, Wardrobe and I had a huge conversation about this hat because it was very camera specific. I had to look like I was being incognito, but you had to be able to see my face. So was it written in the script that you're wearing a hat, and then Wardrobe had to come up with hat choices? Yes. Yeah. So we had about, like, I don't know, five or six hat choices that I had to try on, and they took pictures of me in the hat, and they showed them to, you know, everybody involved. And then also, like, on the day I had that hat, and I think one other hat, and that one showed my face better. Okay. So they went with that one. It didn't have too big of a rim.
我喜欢吉姆的建议最终起到了某种帮助作用。好吧，吉姆确实对德怀特说了一些话。他说，做最真实的自己就行。对。这其实是很棒的建议。这就是真实的你。对。你知道的，你是个独裁者。对。这就是你最本色发挥的方式。对。然后他成功杀死了全场。他太绝了。我们得回到办公室，因为瑞恩正在展现他的傲慢。哦，对，回到了会议室。回到了会议室，他们在处理帕姆的婚礼请柬。凯莉说她想要一场六月的婚礼。她问瑞恩，他想要一场六月的婚礼吗？然后他说，是的，我永远不会结婚，不打算办这事。然后她离开了房间，接着帕姆就说，你知道的，她喜欢你。
So that's the hat that we went with. I love that little touch that she's gone to record her fellow speech. Me too. She's so proud of them. You know, they're sort of meant to be the kind of funny relationship, but they have a really good relationship. They're supportive of one another. They clearly care about one another. It's moments like this that make it so that it's not just a joke. It's not just a joke relationship. These are the moments that ground it and make it real. Listen, Dwight and Angela make perfect sense to me. Yes. They really do, just like Jim and Pam made sense to me when I read that relationship. And obviously, they're going to go through some hills and valleys, but they are meant to be together.
你可以稍微体贴一点。他看着你，然后说，我知道我刚才说了什么。我知道。傲慢。我知道。他就像是，不，我知道我做了什么。瑞恩式的傲慢。对。瑞恩式的傲慢。这也是奥斯卡告诉吉姆他在基韦斯特的分时度假房可能还空着的时候。但接着瑞恩说，我觉得吉姆永远不会真的去旅行。等等，等等，这是我的第三张“瑞恩式傲慢”卡片。那是 17 分钟 34 秒。他说，你真的觉得自己会去吗？给我寄张明信片吧。这到底是怎么回事？我不知道。瑞恩真的太，你知道吗？他真的是。很多粉丝写信来问吉姆到底有没有去旅行。现在，写了这一集的保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）曾做过一次采访，他说，是的，我想吉姆最终确实去了那次旅行，
I like how Jim's advice ends up being kind of helpful. Well, Jim actually says something to Dwight. He's like, just stay true to yourself. Yeah. And that's actually really good advice. This is who you are. Yeah. You know, you're an authoritarian. Yeah. This is how you're going to be most authentic. Yeah. And he kills it. He kills it. We have to go back to the office because there's some Ryan sass happening. Oh yeah, back in the conference room. Back in the conference room, they're doing Pam's wedding invites. And Kelly says she wants a June wedding. And she asked Ryan, would he like a June wedding? And he's like, yeah, I'm never getting married, not really doing it. And she leaves the room and then Pam is like, you know, she likes you.
但他把行程改了。所以他，好吧，我想我们稍后会讲到。我倒觉得他从来没去过那次旅行，因为他最后直接调换工作了。对。这就是他逃离的方式。对。但我觉得他从来没去过那次旅行。我觉得瑞恩是对的。我是说，我不觉得他真的去过。不，我也不觉得。我猜他买机票的那些钱全白花了。对。好吧。所以回到会展中心，你知道的，德怀特的演讲，我们刚才说它真的开始大受欢迎了，而迈克尔离开了。他去了酒吧。对。他受不了了。他无法接受德怀特表现得这么好。我敢打赌，人们大概从来没有对迈克尔的演讲做出过那样的反应。比如人们并没有起哄尖叫。没有。对。所以迈克尔，他坐在酒吧里，最后德怀特走了出来，
You could be a little bit more sensitive. And he looks at you and he's like, I know what I said. I know. Sass. I know. He's like, no, I know what I did. Ryan sass. Yeah. Ryan sass. This is also when Oscar tells Jim that his time share in Key West might be available. But then Ryan says, I don't think Jim will ever really take a trip. Wait, wait, this is my third Ryan sass card. It's 17 minutes, 34 seconds. He says, you really think you're going to go? Send me a postcard. What is happening? I don't know. Ryan is being such a, you know what? He really is. A lot of fans wrote in and asked if Jim ever takes the trip. Now, Paul Lieberstein, who wrote this episode, he did an interview once where he said, yeah, I think Jim did eventually take that trip,
找到了他，并开始向他讲述一个关于某个女人的故事，那个女人坐在那里没有带身份证件，但是，德怀特听得太入迷了。德怀特立刻被迈克尔的故事吸引住了。对。然后迈克尔有这样一句台词，他说，听着，我迷住了那个迷了一千个男人的男人。所以，谁才是今天的赢家？谁才是赢家？好吧。所以，我有一个来自马德琳·埃辛顿（Madeline Ethington）的粉丝提问。好吧。这个，我从来没有这么喜欢过一封邮件。好吧。马德琳。哇。马德琳写信说，我一直在等待这一集来问这个问题。是什么问题，马德琳？在 20 分钟 25 秒时，当迈克尔和德怀特坐在酒吧里时，你能看到背景里有一个人穿着像个巫师。他为什么在那儿？为什么？这是计划好的吗？
but he moved the trip. So he, well, I guess we'll get to that later. I sort of felt like he never took the trip because he just ends up transferring jobs. Yeah. And that's how he gets away. Yeah. But I think he never took the trip. I think Ryan's right. I mean, I don't think he ever goes. No, I don't think so either. I guess he lost all that money for the plane ticket. Yeah. All right. So back at the convention, you know, Dwight speech, we said it's really starting to kill and Michael leaves. He goes to the bar. Yeah. He can't take it. He can't take that Dwight is doing so well. I bet probably people never reacted like that to Michael speech. Like people were not like hooting and hollering. No. Yeah. So Michael, he's sitting at the bar, eventually Dwight comes out and he
这是一场意外吗？然后她又写道，那个巫师到底是谁？我知道这个答案。我也知道。但我，我当时不知道。我去看了，心想，这是最奇怪的问题。我拉到 20 分钟 25 秒，然后笑出了声。我们能看看吗？从头到脚全套巫师装扮。好吧，我拍了照片。你必须让我看看。我，我知道为什么，但我知道是因为我看过被删减的片段。哦，我知道为什么，因为我问过肯特·萨博纳克（Kent Zbornak）和保罗·利伯斯坦，为什么背景里会有一个穿着巫师服装的人？好吧。所以你告诉我你发现了什么，然后我告诉你我发现了什么。他在这儿，安吉拉。对。他戴着名牌呢。好吧，我当然不知道肯特和保罗的答案，但我看过被删减的片段，
finds him and he starts telling him a story about some woman who sat there who didn't have her ID and, and, but Dwight's so into it. Dwight immediately clicks into Michael's story. Yeah. And Michael has this quote where he says, listen, I captivated the guy who captivated a thousand guys. So like, who's the winner today? Who's the winner? Okay. So, and I had a fan question from Madeline Ethington. Okay. This, I've never loved male more than this male. Okay. Madeline. Wow. Madeline wrote and said, I have been waiting for this episode to ask this question. What is it Madeline? At 20 minutes and 25 seconds when Michael and Dwight are sitting at the bar, you can see a man in the background dressed like a wizard. Why is he there? Why? Was it planned?
里面有一段他们穿过会展中心所在酒店的加长镜头。好吧。他们走到看到的第一个房间，走了进去，结果发现走错了。那是一个，类似于，随便什么随机的会议。然后他们走进了第二个房间，里面全都是这些打扮成各种角色进行角色扮演（Cosplay）的人。哦。然后德怀特就说，哦，我希望我，哦，我想来这里。这里好像有一个完整的名字。该死，我记不起那个名字了。但德怀特就想去。然后他说，我真的希望能看到来自《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的那位美女。哦天哪。她太火辣了。好吧。这肯定是即兴发挥的，因为肯特告诉我，他们与喜来登酒店的场地协议允许他们在物业的
Was it an accident? And then she just wrote again, who is that wizard? I know the answer to this. I do too. But I, I didn't know. I went, I was like, this is the strangest question. I went to 20 minutes, 25 seconds and I laughed out loud. Can we see it? Full head to toe wizard. Well, I took a picture. You have to show me. I, I know why, but I know why because I watched the deleted scenes. Oh, I know why because I asked Kent Sabornak and Paul Lieberstein, why is there a man dressed as a wizard in the background? Okay. So you tell me what you found out and I'll tell you what I found out. Here he is, Angela. Yeah. He's got a name tag on. Okay. Well, obviously I don't know Kent and Paul's answer, but I watched the deleted scenes
基本上任何地方拍摄，但唯一被允许关闭并控制的房间只有那个宴会厅。对。否则他们就只能挂起那些牌子，上面写着，如果你走进这个区域，你可能会被拍进一个电视节目中。并且通过走进这个区域，你即表示同意出现在电视节目中。我不知道你们在洛杉矶以外的地方，是否经常在城里看到这些标志。比如，你走进一家餐厅，那里有个牌子，然后你就会想，哦，他们在街上拍摄，我大概会成为背景里买咖啡的路人甲吧。所以他们挂了这些牌子，他说他们必须在拍摄时允许公众通行。而且在其他宴会厅之一正好有一个动漫展。是的。里面有人穿着盛装。所以我想，我想当时
and there is an extended scene of them walking through the hotel where the convention centers are. Okay. And they go up to the very first one they see and they walk in and it's the wrong one. And it's, it's a, like a, just some random convention. And then they go into a second room and it's like all of these cosplay people who are dressed like characters from things. Oh. And Dwight's like, oh, I wish I, oh, I wanted to go to this. It has like a whole name. Damn it, I'm forgetting the name. But Dwight was like, I would have gone. And then he's like, I really hope I see the, the gal from Battlestar Galactica. Oh my God. She's so hot. Okay. This must have been improvised because Kent told me that their location agreement with the Sheridan allowed them to shoot
还有一个加长的镜头，他们走过有会议中心的酒店。好的。他们走到看到的第一个地方，走了进去，结果走错了。那是一个，是一个，就随便什么普通的会议。然后他们走进了第二个房间，里面全都是cosplay的人，他们打扮成各种角色的样子。哦。德怀特就说，哦，我希望我，哦，我想去这个。它好像有个完整的名字。该死，我忘了那个名字了。但德怀特说，我本来会去的。然后他说，我真的很希望我能看到，《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》里的那个姑娘。哦天哪。她太辣了。好吧。这肯定是即兴发挥的，因为肯特告诉我，他们与喜来登酒店的场地协议允许他们在拍摄
basically anywhere on the property, but the only room they were allowed to shut down and control was that ballroom. Yeah. And otherwise they just had those signs up that said, if you walk in this area, you might be filmed for a TV show. And by walking in this area, you give permission to be on the TV show. I don't know if you guys outside of LA, you see these signs a lot around town. Like, you go to a restaurant and there's like a sign and you're like, oh, they're filming on the street and I'm going to be in the background getting my coffee, I guess. So they had these signs up and he said that they just had to allow public access while they were rolling. And there was an anime expo in one of the other ballrooms. Yes. With people dressed up. So I guess, I guess then
基本上物业的任何地方拍摄，但唯一允许他们封闭和控制的房间只有那个宴会厅。是的。除此之外，他们只挂了那些牌子，上面写着，如果你走进这个区域，你可能会被拍进电视节目中。通过走进这个区域，你即表示同意出现在电视节目中。我不知道你们在洛杉矶以外的地方是不是经常在城里看到这些牌子。比如，你走进一家餐厅，有个牌子，然后你会想，哦，他们在街上拍戏，我估计我要在背景里买咖啡了。所以他们挂了这些牌子，他说他们在开机时必须允许公众出入。其中一个宴会厅里正好有一个动漫展。是的。里面有人穿着盛装。所以我想，我猜当时
Rain and Steve improvised this whole thing that it was like a cosplay convention. They must have. And Rain was really, really bummed because, well Dwight was really bummed because he had wanted to go to it. And supposedly there was a Battlestar Galactica cast member that was going to be there and he was like really excited. Oh my gosh. Well, both Kent and Paul said a version of the same thing, which was they really tried to avoid getting the dressed up people in the shots, but this one wizard managed to get on camera. And maybe they had to film that little improv to justify it if they like too many of them showed up at one time. Yeah, that's amazing. The hotel in the show is supposedly the Radisson Lackawanna Station Hotel. Okay. I have stayed
雷恩和史蒂夫即兴发挥了整段内容，感觉就像是在办动漫展。他们肯定是的。雷恩当时真的很沮丧，呃我是说德怀特真的很沮丧，因为他很想去。据说现场会有一个《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的演员，他对此感到非常兴奋。哦天哪。嗯，肯特和保罗都提到了类似的事情，那就是他们极力避免把盛装打扮的人拍进镜头里，但还是有一个“巫师”成功入镜了。也许他们不得不把那段小即兴拍下来以作解释，以防有太多人同时出现。是的，这太神奇了。剧中的酒店据说是雷迪森拉克瓦纳车站酒店。好吧。我住过
there. Oh, we stayed there for the convention. There was an office convention in 2007. And that's where the whole cast stayed. And it's a lovely hotel. It used to be a train station. Yeah. And like 1908, it was a train station and they have fixed it up and made it into this hotel. And it's really nice. So if you're in Scranton, I recommend the Radisson Lackawanna Station Hotel. Well, when the finale happened, a bunch of us went to Scranton for a big parade and we stayed there as well. So I've also stayed there and I concur. It's a great hotel. Great hotel. Super charming. Super charming. So now Dwight and Michael are sort of having this great moment at the bar. They're laughing and it's all wrapping up. But guess who's the last person to touch the thermostat
那里。哦，我们为了那个大会住在那里。2007年有一场办公室粉丝大会。整个剧组都住在那里。那是一家很可爱的酒店。它以前是一个火车站。是的。大约在1908年，它是一个火车站，他们把它修缮成了这家酒店。真的很不错。所以如果你在斯克兰顿，我推荐雷迪森拉克瓦纳车站酒店。好吧，当大结局上演时，我们一堆人去了斯克兰顿参加大游行，我们也住在那里。所以我也是住在那里的，我表示赞同。这是一家很棒的酒店。非常迷人。非常迷人。所以现在德怀特和迈克尔在酒吧里度过了一个美妙的时刻。他们在笑，一切都圆满结束了。但你猜是谁最后碰了
back in the office? Who? Creed. Why did I miss that? Creed goes over there and adjusts the thermostat. He's the last one. I missed that. Well, at the very end of this episode, Jim is passing by Pam's desk and Pam says, oh, I've always wanted to go to Australia. And he says, well, I'm going. I bought a non-refundable ticket and this is when he tells us he bought his ticket for June 8th. Oh, the look on Pam's face. Her wedding is June 10th. I mean, this is so telling. I mean, Pam, if Pam had any doubts at all that this was hard on him, she can't deny it anymore. Yeah, he's leaving. He has basically said to her, I'm sorry, but I cannot be there when you marry someone else. I can't be there. In fact, I have to be on basically the
办公室里的恒温器？是谁？克里德。我怎么漏掉了这个？克里德走过去调了调恒温器。他是最后一个。我漏掉了这个。好吧，在这个集的最后，吉姆路过帕姆的桌子，帕姆说，哦，我一直想去澳大利亚。他说，嗯，我要去了。我买了一张不能退款的机票，这就是他告诉我们他买的是6月8日的机票的时候。哦，帕姆脸上的表情。她的婚礼是6月10日。我的意思是，这太说明问题了。我是说，帕姆，如果帕姆对这件事对他有多大打击还有任何怀疑的话，她再也无法否认了。是的，他要走了。他基本上是在对她说，我很抱歉，但当你要嫁给别人时，我无法出席。我无法出席。事实上，我必须去基本上是
farthest spot on the earth from your wedding. Yeah. I'm going to go halfway around the world. Yeah. To get away from your wedding. I mean, I just, it just gutted me and I just, I just wanted to shake Pam and be like, if you don't know now, then you'll never know. He loves you. But I think it's more than that. I think what's happening is Jim is saying, I'm not sure how to even be your friend now that you're getting married. Like, I know we're best friends at the office, but I'm not going to come to your wedding. And when you're married, I'm not going to hang with you. He's, you know, I think what he's finally admitting is they're, they're not best friends. Yeah, they can't. How can they be? They've crossed this line. They've had that moment on booze cruise. They've had these
离你的婚礼最远的地方。是的。我要去地球的另一端。是的。来躲开你的婚礼。我的意思是，我只是，这简直让我心碎，我只想摇晃帕姆并对她说，如果你现在还不明白，那你永远也不会明白了。他爱着你。但我觉得不仅如此。我觉得发生的事情是吉姆在说，既然你都要结婚了，我都不知道该怎么当你的朋友了。就像，我知道我们在办公室是最好的朋友，但我不会去参加你的婚礼。当你结婚后，我也不会和你鬼混。你知道的，我觉得他最终承认的是，他们，他们不是最好的朋友。是的，他们不能是。怎么可能呢？他们已经越过了这条线。他们在酒船上经历过那个时刻。他们现在经历了这些
moments now and the line has been crossed. Yeah. And now they're in this uncharted territory of like, what do we do now? What's next week's episode? Take your daughter to work day, I think. Yeah. Oh boy. This is when you guys, I was wrong. Okay. I use the shredder. Oh, okay. All right. So, I'll get, I'll get the time code for that so I can really lay into myself. Yeah. Take your daughter to work day is coming up next week. All right, you guys, that was Dwight speech. Thanks so much for tuning in. Bye. Bye. See you next week. Thank you for listening to office ladies. Office ladies is produced by ear Wolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Gratton. For ad free versions
时刻，界限已经被跨越了。是的。现在他们处于这种未知的领域，比如，我们现在该怎么办？下周的节目是什么？带女儿上班日，我想。是的。哦天哪。这就是你们，我错了。好吧。我用了碎纸机。哦，好吧。好吧，我会把那段的时间码找出来，这样我就可以好好反省一下自己了。是的。下周将迎来带女儿上班日。好了，各位，那是德怀特的演讲。非常感谢收听。再见。再见。下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Ear Wolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮费尔。我们的主题曲是克里德·格拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关无广告版本的
of the show and our bonus episodes candy bag, go to Stitcher premium.com for a free one month trial of Stitcher premium use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目以及我们的彩蛋节目“糖果袋”，请访问Stitcher premium.com，使用优惠码office即可免费试用一个月的Stitcher premium。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。